[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
ta-da please
god tell me this [ __ ] microphone is
working today yeah
i mean hopefully it's working i've
recorded a bunch of [ __ ] with it today
and it seems to sound fine
you've got to go ahead and read out that
[ __ ] super chat marin
thank you yes thank you aaron for it
being 60 degrees in indiana and i'm in a
good mood
all right you got your drink out here
and i got time travelers in there
fighting in the damn
comment section trying to find out
what the other one is doing in the
future
the fight between time zones it's
[ __ ] uh
yeah i forgot about the time traveling
element yeah yeah
time zone times time zone fight yeah
that's like the next direct-to-sci-fi
movie tammy says it sounds great
good because man i went in there figured
it out
you know what i well i figured out what
i think it is
right my obs program decided
that it was going to add without any
input from yours truly it was going to
add
the internal microphone on top of this
microphone and it was going to record
both things at the same time yes it was
run the laptop
mic and then external mic simultaneously
why who knows
that program does that every now and
then it does weird [ __ ]
it it changes it changes uh
selections or you know what i mean or
changes options without you actually
asking for that
it's some kind of error it's a ghost
yeah
[ __ ] ghostly zach says tom did you
show jenny the video of the guy talking
like your dad
nah i was in another room there's a
he was at the doctor's office and they
had old black dude in the
in the [ __ ] wheelchair talking and
his is he
he sounded like how i sound when i'm
taking my dad's voice
he kind of did a little bit
[Laughter]
he's gonna want me to imitate that voice
well yeah only i could sound like me
nobody else sounds like me that's
ridiculous
[Laughter]
it sounds like you talking about your
dad i said yeah man
why are you banging that's a [ __ ]
supernatural chance
yeah you know [ __ ] ebonics is
southern we all kind of sound alike
especially when you get older
once you get a certain age everybody
sounds like all right
when i'm on the show you know
my accent's in in check really this is
more of my neutral
accent that i just used this is the sexy
newscaster
[Laughter]
but when i'm around when i'm gonna go
down when i go to mississippi and around
my dad it just
it goes [ __ ] it goes [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] super southern real quick
i don't you don't think about it it's
just when i hear that
dialect i respond in it without thinking
well i think that's something that a lot
of people do because i
i know when i was in the uk for you know
a long time
and then i came back my you know my mom
would be like why are you talking funny
and it's like i didn't really realize
but be when you're around people that
have a different accent than you all the
time and sometimes you just like pick it
up whether you're aware of it or not
but that's what ended up happening look
i got a different drink today it's pink
this is actually cherry vodka and sprite
with a little bit of grenadine and a
little bit of splash of lemon juice in
it yeah
i don't know why it's like sometimes i
get that at eye bar like i get
cherry vodka with sprite and uh i don't
know it just sounded good we were at the
liquor store today because we already
drank all the whipped cream vodka
although both of us were drinking that
it wasn't just me i'm drinking what you
call in mississippi then mississippi you
call this that's a 50 50 bar
50 50.
[Laughter]
in other places would be called
creamsicle yes
i it's one of those ice creams it's got
orange it's like an orange popsicle with
cream filling
that's what it is it's uh yeah those are
good yeah
pinnacle whipped cream vodka and orange
juice
it's [ __ ] delicious we had an
addictive addictive it is yeah
it gets a little sweet after a while you
have to kind of temper it with something
else that's why i kind of
i don't know and the beauty of pinnacle
is that it tastes [ __ ] great it's
cheap
yeah artificially what is it like 12
bucks a bottle like for a big ass
yeah yeah they get all kind of crazy
flavors it's just artificially flavored
[ __ ]
vodka but they all do it now smirnoff
does it [ __ ] they're they all do that
now
i really like lemon vodka although you
have to really and grapefruit
vodka too you like you really can't and
you can't
drink too much of it because it's real
acidic so it'll give you like really bad
heartburn if you drink too much of it
or it'll make you puke or i'll make me
pee okay if i drink too much of it
i have like more than three oh they're
trying to get me to talk about dinner
talk like dennis
richard the rich of the hut says hey
jenny and tom i can't stay but i'll
catch the re-upload
they're just they're just popping in to
say hello hello sorry you can't say but
it'll be here tomorrow
the man has made it to the party
sandra's made it to the party
yeah it's sandra i drank something
mangoes mango
and [ __ ] it was mango
pineapple and guava nectar
yeah with vod with uh vodka in it yeah
yeah delicious dennis and fish should
make an appearance center
dennis and fish albert fish oh albert
fish i don't know
nobody knows about albert fish well see
they're going to bring down the statues
i have well do i have i have h.h holmes
back here jess not albert fish
i'm not sure what i i don't know what hh
home sounds like but i imagine him
sounding like one of those turn of the
century like carnival barker type of
dudes
probably you know what i mean or like
those old you know those old um
not uh not silent films obviously
because you wouldn't be able to hear it
duh
but um those kind of like war
era newsreels that they used to show in
uh
movie theaters and stuff and now over
the thing blah blah blah
i kind of i kind of feel like that's
what hh holmes would talk about okay
[Laughter]
h.h helms would have had that speech
pattern
that i always hear in pathological liars
though he was a pathological liar
so it would have been like yeah yeah
that's what it is yeah
one of those yeah yeah did you see yeah
sure you know he'd
be he'd be like that why don't you uh
come with me and we'll uh we'll we'll
take a ride in this carriage and um
i'll put you in this trunk it'll be okay
i'll put you in the trunk it'll be okay
i'll even poke holes in it for you yeah
she can breathe right here
okay and then you'll be okay i'll let
you i'm gonna call you i'm gonna
i got a letter going out to your mom she
she's on her way yeah she said it was
okay for me to put you in the truck
oh yeah oh you didn't know that you
didn't know that
yeah yeah i'm allowed to put you in a
trunk any time i want to
guess what your mom said
that's the way that's where he should hh
homes would talk it would not shock me
at all if he tried to pull that crap
yeah
and this is like some little kid to be
like are you sure okay
no no it's okay i mean think about it
it's not like i would do anything like
sell your skeleton or anything you know
i wouldn't sell your particular anything
that's right i'm meaningless
a little girl skeleton wouldn't be worth
anything you know so
no it'd be okay go ahead go ahead and
get in there
i'll uh i'll i'll talk to you in a
minute i'll talk to you in a minute i'll
talk to you man
nice and comfortable it's not so
comfortable want a pillow
[Laughter]
trying to put myself oh my god yeah now
i kind of want to see
like a black comedy yeah hh helms where
he talks like that
right look man that'd be horrifying
you know i hate to like [ __ ] you know
pigeon hole and
pathological liars all have that same
[ __ ]
they all have that same speech pattern
all i gotta do is just listen to [ __ ]
interviews with them a lot when they're
telling the truth they don't sound like
that
but when they start lying they do that
it's it's like nervous ticks
i grew up with one yeah you know i
didn't say his name
but um i grew up i grew up when one went
to school with one
and uh i i learned early on that that's
what they sound like
and then every other person that sounded
like that was a [ __ ] liar
i always kind of feel like that speech
pattern
yeah it almost sounds like after every
single sentence they're saying
do you buy that yeah exactly that's what
that's like to me thank you ken read it
out for the impromptu impersonation
yeah i'll miss you tonight thank you
very much oh i'm sorry he said he had to
work
i'd like to thank you very much i'll be
back in a minute yeah see you could be
the you could be generations rich little
yeah all the young people like who the
[ __ ] is rich little
we're all going to have a big get
together tonight in graceland
[Music]
orion's coming
[Laughter]
are you lonesome tonight
[Laughter]
yeah oh my god i would pay a substantial
amount if you would get like a really
good elvis wig
yeah you don't need a wig nobody knows
what i just grow my hair out nobody
knows what elvis looked like at my age
and [ __ ] died young 42.
true yeah if it was really him yeah it
was him
yeah i know wake up sheeple
no i'm trying to like be all conspiracy
theory
about [ __ ] yeah so
yeah we so yeah we are probably somebody
mentioned earlier um
that we've been talking about moving the
main shows to friday night
which probably we will start doing this
week you know didn't we didn't we
talk about that what's up moving the
main show to friday night
yeah we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
do the main show friday so we didn't go
out on saturday it's about that time
about time to start
start it back up gotta go out to the
clubs you can't live like this man
it's like tila just rolled in yeah
so tom you can't sing an elvis song
without standing up a giant in your head
well yeah that's but that's i had to
really get warmed up to do elvis
yeah he's got it he's got to be pretty
drunk for you can you do that well also
my voice hasn't been trained in a while
it would actually take me a couple
months to get back in shape
i could do that i couldn't i couldn't do
elvis at his [ __ ] peak
you know what i mean he could [ __ ]
sing yeah really [ __ ] say
but like a fake elvis pretty good you
know
yeah right but um no he
don't get me started on elvis though
[Laughter]
anyway no [ __ ] but it's true
after hearing what a liar sounded like
what a pathological i mean the guy that
i was talking about
he did have some kind of a mental
problem it was impossible for him to
tell the truth
he couldn't tell the truth some people
have that
yeah and once i kind of picked up the
that
those mannerisms saw what they were and
got that
[ __ ] feeling i would get a certain
feeling you know
around it that every other person i got
that feeling from was also a liar
a pathological liar they all have that
same personality
tics and personality traits and that was
part of
my journey into going from an
enlightened human being
to a more superficial human being
because being
[ __ ] do yeah that's inspirational
[Laughter]
i used to be enlightened and [ __ ] you
know what i mean
yeah high-minded but no once i became
very superficial
i ended up having a greater success rate
in dealing with people
um yeah it's
it's true though but that kind of gave
me the ability to detect a good person
um you know what i mean yeah because i
could detect bad ones
you know before we even going out i was
telling you that motherfucker's bad that
mother
i was telling you yeah and then that
[ __ ] [ __ ] would come true
i could just sense it yeah and it and
it's not a psychic ability
it's just like the same way a mentalist
reads a person
you know body language where they
position themselves in a room
the the tones used in the voices the
lack of eye contact or too much contact
or just observational stuff
and you you you don't do it on purpose
you just do it
instinctively you go like that
motherfucker's bad
most people are trying to shut other
people out so they don't notice what
other people
are doing i was always i had a very good
situational awareness
because of my life i was very aware yeah
and most of the motives i found in
people weren't these high-minded good
motors these [ __ ] are in the
gutter you know and the more of a person
tried to convince me that they're a good
person the
worse off they were it's always a person
who's kind of indifferent doesn't really
care about how you feel
about you because they're going about
their own business and just being good
if a person has to go out of their way
to tell you that they're good there's
they're bad
well like i said it's just like anything
else it's like if you were a good person
or if you were like a cool person you
don't have to go around going hey
guess what i'm a good person yeah i'm a
good person everyone would just know and
they don't really do it that way they're
constantly trying to put themselves
above others
you know or try to shine brighter than
others and it's because there's a
problem
just be cool everybody chill out chill
out let's see what everybody's doing
i was gonna is pookie still in here yeah
she's in here
okay she's i didn't know if she'd gone
outside yet he's dead i did watch elvis
in the black community videos requested
i also saw a bug
okay yeah the old one or the newish one
i don't know because like i said
there was one that came out in the 90s
or 2000s with michael shannon in it
which is also really good but it's a
completely different movie
no i liked i liked bug bug was a [ __ ]
weird man
i don't know what they were doing par
something's missing
that's what they were doing there was
gonna be more to that movie instead dude
just jumped down in the hole and blew up
i was like that's no it's just never not
not gonna be funny that [ __ ] happened
and that [ __ ] happened he jumped in that
[ __ ]
in that ravine and blew up and then the
vn came up
jenny is my witness i went no no way no
yeah he jumped up
no yeah i just yeah no no
that wasn't supposed to end like that i
wanted to be like mst they'd be like
that's how you want to end it movie yeah
that's how you want to end it okay i was
tripping
the dude exploded dude exploded
although i mean how many movies end with
a dude exploding not not that many not
enough
i i would submit you know what i mean
yeah just i don't know why it's because
i was just thinking about mystery
science theater again but i think it was
um the incredible melting man and i
remember
i think it was crow said at the end he's
like man how many monster movies end
with the monster getting scooped up into
a garbage
can which it actually does
because he like melts so much that he
just looks like what they called like a
bunch of day old manicotti
on the side of the [ __ ] wall and the
janitor's like what the [ __ ] is all this
mess that sweeps it all up and puts in
the garbage can
which i thought was very funny
additional terror that's what that was
yeah if you guys were here for a
lingering video yesterday which the
sound was
[ __ ] shitty on i was i was laughing
about additional terror
that's what i'm going to call my band i
don't know why that was so funny to me
because he said well wasn't it
additional terrors like they will need
additional terrors today i'm like no
there's
additional terror which to me was like a
hundred times funnier
than additional terror or terrors tail
wars another good one you might want to
see t
is um john carpenter and [ __ ] crustle
kurt russell
i call him crustal i don't know if you
were around during the crusal sphere
era of this show but i have i believe in
something called the crusal sphere it's
very much like the [ __ ] force
kurt russell and the sphere of things
around kurt russell and how i am
connected to this
sphere of crossover kurt russell
kurt russell is condensed into one word
russell yeah crustal yeah
it's like a holy word from the crust
kirk ross
i can't explain oh my god we should
totally make a church of crustal
church across the t-shirt somehow kurt
russell's connected
with something okay with the entire
universe yes
yeah kurt russell is the meaning of the
universe
but john carpenter and kurt russell made
a badass
made for television movie it was long
it's like three hours
it's called elvis it was made for tv you
can get it on blu-ray and dvd and you
could probably
read it it's really good really good and
kurt russell
does a [ __ ] fantastic elvis he is
really good
really good at it yeah scott says
crustal sprouts
crustal sprouts [ __ ] right that's
that's that's what his kids are looking
goomies
[Laughter]
another really good elvis movie that i
like was one it was called elvis and
nixon
and the whole movie is about the time
elvis presley
went to the white house to meet richard
nixon president richard nixon and the
[ __ ] that went down
the crazy [ __ ] that went down during
that
era of elvis's life
he was really at a war with himself at
that time and drugs
you know and he was kind of a
elvis was kind of a kind of a
contradiction
he was um a lot of things had built up
in his life that were
kind of like the opposite of what he
considered himself
to be you know he was no longer kind of
this traditional southern
family oriented guy he was now a
california la kind of a guy
and uh he was now addicted to drugs
painkillers but he really couldn't admit
that to himself he wanted to become a
secret agent
and stop drugs from infiltration and
hard rock music i think because he
didn't
like the rolling stones it was just
which
seems excessively like shooting yourself
in the dick i mean yeah
you know right i have a lot of theories
you know that was one of the reasons why
eddie murphy i think was so interested
trying to trying to get down to the
bottom of who and what elvis was
and in the in the end elvis didn't know
what elvis was
he was he was having a uh well
back in those days they would have
called it a midlife crisis but there's
more he was having hormonal difficulties
is that what we're calling it now i'm
gonna call it now okay
well that's well the thing about it you
have to understand though i mean
he came from a really really poor uh
you know background and for somebody to
come up and be that famous i
you know how can you remain a normal
person
yeah i mean it's got to be really really
really he was one of the first
one of the very first mega stars and he
had never left the united states for an
international tour
he had only toured the united states
yeah he went overseas he was a tanker in
the army
and served as just a regular soldier he
didn't want any special treatment
it was good and his commanding generally
met the daughter and that was
that was priscilla and priscilla was
gorgeous i mean that was a good looking
girl it was just he lived a very
unique life especially for his time um
he was one of the first mega stars
really
and and he i don't think he could really
wrap his head around it
and he kind of lost well who could yeah
he lost his career in his 30s and around
the time
man's kind of normal hormone production
kind of [ __ ] tapers off
and he lost a lot of confidence which i
think sent him into a spiral he didn't
feel
a spiral spiral of depression he didn't
feel good
so um and i think he might have gotten
injured i got to go back and
i think he got injured on stage and then
they prescribed him some
painkillers and i think that's where it
started and he got it that's where it
starts with a lot of people and he
got addicted to those painkillers and
just
they tried to take his his the memphis
mob tried to
which was his buddies they tried to take
those painkillers from him while he was
in bed
eating in bed you know and he pulled
that 45 out on him says you're not
taking my medicine you know
he was he was addicted
but he couldn't admit it to himself and
that he never
really he tried to make a quick little
comeback
in his uh 30s which he did good
um but he just couldn't maintain it and
i kind of know what i know now you know
he dying at 42
that those drugs and him coming off that
real
living that high life and then kind of
losing his career
i know his [ __ ] his his testosterone
must have been [ __ ] way down in the
dumps probably like
a hundred decim nanoliters for death
or what he got nanograms per deciliter
you know which he's probably pretty in
pretty bad shape hormonally
and it'll make you just feel like [ __ ]
but they didn't have anything back then
that could have helped him
i wonder too if he's not gaining all
that weight thank you zach
and his last concert was right here in
indy indiana
i wonder sometimes too if he had i feel
like a lot of famous or well-known
or successful people have this if they
had kind of like that weird like
imposter syndrome
you know what i mean where it's kind of
like you know you have all this money
and
all this fame and everything and then
but like deep down you don't think you
deserve it because you're not good
enough
i wonder if he had some of that going on
too i don't know
he knew he could sing yeah but but i
think that that level
once you get to that level of fame i
think it's really really hard for people
unless they're complaining
i think he lost when he got about 35
and his career started to kind of take
because he wasn't as popular as he was
he started to go out of style
yeah that that started it the problem he
went into a spiral of depression and
drug abuse
which tanked his testosterone levels and
he would have never recovered without
some kind of [ __ ] hormone therapy
because getting him off the drugs
wouldn't have restarted his testosterone
production
at that time so just continue to got
fatter and fatter and he would have
continued to have less and less energy
he said he felt bad all the time yeah
lacking energy
part of it was those painkillers part
part of it was
probably very low testosterone because
if you get addicted to [ __ ]
um any kind of painkillers your
testosterone production just almost
ceases
sheila anne asked how far tupelo was
from where you grew up in
mississippi it was about an hour away
yeah yeah i mean it's not a massive it's
all those towns are about the same
though especially back in those
in those days yeah graham townsend said
when you become that famous you become a
caricature of yours yeah
yeah that was what you mean it's hard
not to yeah elvis was a meme of himself
he knew that
i can't imagine trying to be a real
person
yeah and and then on the other hand like
being this
massive like icon yeah
people don't even see as a person yeah
in a time when that was not the normal
phenomenon yeah
he was one of the first to kind of go
that route
as a as a musician so it was uh
he didn't know how to handle it because
he had no forebearers if you know what
i'm talking about yeah
he was the first to be like that and
evidently he was like that for his whole
life even when he looked kind of [ __ ]
up and said he could walk into a room
and everybody would just [ __ ] freeze
yeah because it was like like royalty
like god had just walked in because his
image proceed his
uh his image was larger than life you
know and uh
he had a huge cultural impact on people
back in those days
he was an icon while he was alive yeah
that was part of his problem i don't
think he'd go to anybody for help and
what how could they help him
they didn't have the technology to help
him they wouldn't have known what the
deal was
yeah i kind of feel like back in those
days sadly
um particularly when men had problems or
mental problems and stuff it was
like i was just sucking up yeah men had
mental problems back in the 50s and 60s
70s he died
yeah actually even the 80s you just did
he says well your time is up time for
you to go yeah so they just
because they just they don't want to
talk about their feelings for christ's
sake
a lot of people don't know what their
feelings are that's true
good or they don't want to like betray
any weakness by saying they don't
you know that they're not feeling well
they usually kill themselves
you lose a job you lose a purpose in
life and [ __ ] then they just kind of
hormonally crash go to [ __ ] age real
rapidly after that and die
either either they just drink themselves
in debt they kill themselves
or the body just shuts down and other
diseases get them
because a lot of people don't realize
that what kills you in the end the [ __ ]
that you
have been carrying in you probably for
decades it's just that you're strong
enough to keep it a check
and you know keep it off at bay but then
your immune system starts to falter and
you just can't hold it off anymore
some virus gets you that you picked up a
long time ago cancer you know
cancer you're fighting cancer all the
time
yeah your body's eliminated in it
usually you get weak you can't fight the
cancer off you you got some kind of
cancer in you somewhere
but your body's constantly attacking it
yeah i mean most of the time people
forget like your immune system is like
constantly
constantly working on top of that right
but it's just there comes a time when
it can't i i remember like reading
somewhere i don't know if this is still
true or not because this is it's been a
few years since i read this
but i read somewhere that if that if
everybody lived long enough
everybody would eventually get cancer
yeah you know i mean just because
it's like a copying error so it's just
like the more your [ __ ] cells like
you know copy themselves eventually it's
going to happen and your
body is not going to be able to deal
with it that's a that's a cheerful
thought
t's talking about those fried peanut
butter banana sandwiches yeah
his cook him and his cook were trying to
figure that out
what they were doing is i got it in the
cookbook
elvis was trying to um he was trying to
replicate
a sandwich that a friend of his so who
owned a restaurant was selling to him
called fool's gold yeah we put that in
the cup that's in the cookbook
food's gold he would charge elvis 100
bucks
for that well illness had a hundred
bucks for a sandwich what it was
it was like some italian bread or french
a whole loaf a whole loaf of italian
bread
and then you had you toasted it you put
melted peanut butter on it a whole jar
of whole jar peanut butter
uh i think it had grape jelly yeah when
an old jar
and about nine slices of [ __ ] bacon
and like half a pound of bacon and a
half head of bacon on and then you put
it and that was step
in one massive locomotive yeah and
that's fool's gold
it's about 100 bucks
[Laughter]
hopefully you don't eat it all at once
but knowing elvis he probably did i
don't even think i could probably eat
maybe like uh the end and maybe a little
bit more and i'd be like yeah i don't
need it anymore
yeah that's a lot yeah t um
yeah [ __ ] kurt russell played elvis
in an old
television made for television movie
yeah it's called elvis it's called elvis
yeah kurt russell and um john carpenter
directed it
and it's good movie real good um you i
got it on
it blue ray yeah and it's it's it's long
but i think they
they broadcast it over like two or three
nights but yeah it was really really
good and kurt russell like makes a
really really good elvis i thought
yeah it doesn't go into elvis's decline
really
it's just his early life and then yeah
it ended
like pretty much when he had his
comeback
right and then like that's the end of it
because i think they were talking about
that it's like they didn't want
he wanted to be negative to be all
negative and like end up with and then
he died because everybody knew that i
think it came out only like a month
later or a year after yeah yeah after he
died so they wanted something that was
more
his fans were pulling out there right
yeah yeah which i can see that
yeah now elvis did rise from the grave
he came back
this is well known all throughout
mississippi thank you zach yeah
peanut butter and uh peanut butter and
almond butter are the [ __ ] they are yeah
yeah
i love almond and actually i love cashew
butter but that [ __ ] is so [ __ ]
expensive then i'll buy it that happen
elvis came back this guy named orion
put out records and everything you
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
and uh orion would go out on stage with
the masks
with the mask and sing all these songs
and write original songs and everything
and it was just it was like elvis back
from the grave and they kept [ __ ]
with you saying
hinting that maybe somehow this is elvis
come back in the grave even though he
was way too old
so but what was it was it was it it was
his spirit being channeled through him
you know what i mean
yeah i'm not trying to spin it that way
too
just leave it nebulous leave it nebulous
and
orion was from mississippi too he could
sound just like that
yeah they he did sound crazy
just like creepily like elvis yeah
i mean and some people have said that
maybe he was related to elvis
everybody's kind of related to everybody
down well yeah that's true
been that especially in that era before
more people moved there
yeah i could see that
everybody's some kind of cousin that's
why all that shocking [ __ ] about all you
guys are [ __ ] your cousins just well
the entire states are cousins well it's
like we don't have a lot of choice here
every yeah
if you were to actually probably do if
you were to actually do an investigative
[ __ ]
investigative work with genealogies and
[ __ ] you probably find out that
all of japan is a cousin you know
i remember i once met a girl just at
random
at like um that's like a mosquito in
here or something yeah um
at like the daycare that my parents used
to run
and it turned out that we had the same
great grandfather of all things
because she was talking about her great
grandfather one day i'm like hey that's
my friend
i'm like that's really weird i never met
her before
very very strange um yeah mango said the
carpenter elvis film was a tv movie but
it was released in cinemas in the uk
yeah okay which yeah i could see that it
was great yeah i really liked it
one of the best elvis movies and
actually the uh but elvis uh
elvis meat was what was called elvis and
um
um nixon elvis and nixon was great
really good that showed elvis in his uh
in his crazy time but it made sense if
you [ __ ]
understood what what was uh
elvis goes to the [ __ ] white house
and they're all carrying guns
you know that's another thing the secret
service like you guys are playing
against oh we all have we're all
carrying concealed yeah
they all had 1911's [ __ ] all engraved
1911. they were like whoa whoa whoa whoa
and he goes
we're not shooting about well i'm a
veteran we're all carrying legally i'm
not like i said
we'll surrender our firearms they're
surrendering their firearms and [ __ ]
he wanted to give nixon a [ __ ] pistol
and it had been
in a big presentation case and [ __ ]
which he did
and then he wanted to be in the fbi he
wanted to be a secret agent
for the fbi to stop drugs and the
[ __ ] nixon's looking like what the
[ __ ] you talking about he's
you're on all the drugs yeah he's like
he's and then he should have said no
that's
well that's good because like i have
experience so i know what to look for
well the most ridiculous part of the
whole thing
is that is that elvis said that he was
willing to go undercover
to go undercover anywhere to [ __ ]
stop oh that he was
kind of like elvis could go undercover
yeah
i'm really not elvis i look like him but
i'm not elvis
it's gonna go undercover then some bubba
yeah yeah yeah i know i kind of look
like elvis but
no and i don't know i sound like elvis
and i know that they have yeah we're
related but
i'm not ill yeah i don't think that
would work i'm just here to buy
17 pounds of cocaine
throw a little bit of heroin in here
[Laughter]
i do understand that i'm the inventor
the original inventor of bling
[Laughter]
oh my god oh my god
cocaine and bling yeah just put that in
the back of the caddy okay
i'll eat it here yeah um
grantham's hammer says david lee roth
calls his member little elvis
oh [ __ ] ew i didn't want to think about
david lee roth's dick right now
[Laughter]
that was another one that was [ __ ]
yeah i can say nothing but
man why you want to get me on dave lee
roth man
i went to high school with this guy yeah
you got some stories about danny roth
probably
yeah no i don't know david lee raw no i
know i'm just kidding yeah
he didn't age well he looks like a
skinny little he's just skinny looking
but you know i guess well he was always
skinny i kind of feel like all those
heavy metal bands all those hair metal
bands and [ __ ] like that ladies i think
they hoovered up all the cocaine
they didn't leave any for anybody else
yeah that's why there's no cocaine left
because they did it all
back in the 80s
we need more elvis played by bruce
campbell i agree we need more everything
played by bruce campbell he should kind
of play
everything well since we're talking
about
music somebody asked us to
talk about the history of the goth
subculture okay do you want to kind of
talk about that
yeah go ahead you start i mean we could
talk about
you know you wanted to talk about heat
as well too you can talk about that
first if you want
well if i get to it i'll talk to it if
you get to it if i get to it yeah
you knew it was based on a true story
right no oh it is
i didn't know yeah it didn't matter it
was it was just a cops of robbers movies
pretty good
yeah yeah it is based on a real guy yeah
it was good well like a real crew and
like a lot of the [ __ ] that happened in
there like really happened
kind of like the apocalypse now of cop
movies
even though it wasn't really a cop movie
it was a cop movie and a robber movie
well that's why they call it both yeah
yeah yeah what i thought was funny about
that movie is that you look at those
guys
you look at them today most of that
movie holds up
some of the stuff that doesn't hold up
is the acting
and it's the acting from the biggest
stars
that don't doesn't really hold up that
well for instance al pacino
the way he the way he played that role
is the way he plays every [ __ ] role
it's like al pacino playing himself
he's just [ __ ] you know i mean
chewing the [ __ ] out of the scenery he's
always been one of those like
larger than one yeah over the [ __ ]
actors [ __ ]
little sawed-off [ __ ] you don't
mean to sit there just
and i'll tell you just over and over and
over again you really couldn't get away
with that
nowadays unless you were already a movie
star that's something that only a movie
star can do
you know what i mean and it's a very big
difference between an actor and a movie
star
actors can become movie stars but once
they become a movie star they're no
longer actors
think about it well that's what i keep
saying it's like that's why
like people like tom cruise and stuff
like that because
you're not really the difference between
a movie star and actor i think
is if you're an actor if you can
disappear into the role yeah do i forget
that you are an actor that you were that
actor
if i forget that you were that person
and you know think that you were the
character then you were an actor if
you're a movie star i can't ever get
past
you being you if they were reshooting
that move they were shooting that movie
today and some dude
an unknown named al pacino showed up and
did that roll that way they kick his ass
off
who the [ __ ] are you you know right and
it's because that's al pacino the only
reason why he's getting away with that
because he's al pacino she's already a
movie star that's what they paid him to
do
you know what i mean but if that was an
unknown actor they would they just
wouldn't tolerate it
although you know what i i will tell you
right now i love al pacino i'm saying
that
but when i saw the first time i saw a
scent of a woman
i think i saw it in the theater it was
pretty good and he just kept doing that
thing all the time and i was like i am
going to punch you right in the [ __ ]
tank the next time it was still a good
movie though god damn it it was yeah
there's still a good movie but
the huawei thing he shouldn't they first
of all he didn't do his research
all right only a [ __ ] would go hoo-ha
that's not that's not what it is it's
poo that's what it is
who uh get the [ __ ] out of here
you know that's something he read in a
script but he's not a serviceman he
definitely out of the infantry i don't
even remember what that movie was about
i remember
the only time i ever heard who uh like
that was a group of [ __ ] nurses
got dismissed and there all six of them
six seven and one
and we laughed [ __ ] army nurses
yeah we laughed
[Laughter]
it's that's what it is
like somebody just punched in the
stomach no it's the it's
execution yeah
you know it's just the command of
executes the thing that makes you do
something
yeah forward whoo that's what it is
i just keep getting mosquito if i keep
going like that there's like a mosquito
yeah a little it's not a skin it's a nat
oh okay that's good well i thought i saw
like a big huge mosquito in here earlier
and i was just kind of like oh my god
i'm gonna get encephalitis
um yeah zach said uh upsettingly
pacino's only oscar win yeah that's the
only oscar he ever got was percent of a
woman and i was like that's probably
like my least favorite movie of his he
would say he's not an actor he's a he's
a he's a [ __ ]
he's a personality he's a personality
he's a movie star
you know and then there's another one
that can act another
oh what's his name [ __ ] dustin
hoffman can act
he can pretty much become something when
he's doing a role
yeah when he cares some of that [ __ ] he
phoned in
but uh some of the [ __ ] that he he did
he did a good job
you know but you know what there are
other unknowns that can
even top that politics has a lot to do
with it
it's easier if you're unknown because
you're not recognizable
so people are a lot more willing to you
know accept you
as this random person in this movie
rather than
an actor hollywood hollywood was always
about
popularity money casting couch and
cocaine
that's what it was about honestly i
don't know why i just thought of this
but
two of the roles that really surprised
me with how
um how famous the people were but also
how i kind of forgot that they were
playing a part
was uh charlize theron in monster
playing alien warnos seeing that movie
in the theater
i forgot that alien warners was dead
i thought i was watching her yeah on the
[ __ ] because she was
[ __ ] amazing i totally forgot
that that wasn't that that was an
actress yeah um the other one
would be martin landau playing bella
lugosi
yeah ed wood again i forgot bella
because he was dead like when i was
watching that
edward is a masterpiece i love that
movie that way
i could watch that all day long that's
[ __ ] good i've seen it so many times
and it's like
that's you know [ __ ] old what's his
name
[ __ ] um what's the director of that
name again [ __ ]
tim burton danberg yeah tim burton can
do some tim burton any type tim burton
burton-ness you know i mean he can do
some tim burton it's bernie burton
yeah but ed wood i think is his
best movie and it's not very tim
burton-y
it doesn't have a lot of that tim
burtitude in it
you know mars attacks is pretty cool um
i need to watch that again i think they
just put it on hulu the other day
yeah that's pretty funny um i mean he
had good movies you know
yeah he did the first two batman i think
at least the first batman i don't know i
don't know if he doesn't know if he did
the second one
first batman was pretty good now he was
gonna do one
that had nick nicholas cage as superman
but they scrapped it imagine a [ __ ]
nicholas cage shut up as a [ __ ]
superman i saw
saw him in the suit and everything he
had long hair long brown hair see i
would watch that he had like a green
crystal [ __ ] cape
suit looking thing it was weird yeah i
remember it yeah it was gonna have kind
of like that uh it was gonna look like
something from
beetlejuice yeah yeah it was gonna real
tim burton
see i mean i could i could watch that
yeah tila said she likes sleepy hollow
too yeah i really like sleepy hollow
and big fish was also really good i
think i saw that in the theater as well
the um
sweeney todd i actually liked that
musical sweeney todd i liked it
you know what i saw that in the theater
as well and then
i didn't i liked it but i didn't love it
like when we saw it like when i saw the
theater a long time ago
but we just rewatched it a few months
ago and i liked it much better
i guess because i just wasn't used to
like johnny depp's singing
so every time he started singing i'm
like stop it he can sing
i know i don't know why it bothered me i
was like knock it off
seth says i'm currently doing a tim
burton themed nursery
that's pretty cool yeah i wonder what
it's like yeah send us pictures
yeah let's see what that looks like
i haven't seen big eyes yet that's the
one about that artist right like that
that did those crazy uh portraits with
like of the children with the big heads
and stuff because i remember i had some
of those when i was a kid
or my mom bought them for me so yeah
that was the one i think it was about
like the like there was a woman that
drew all of those and then like
her husband like took credit or
something i don't remember what it was
but it was something like that i've been
wanting to see that one but i haven't
seen it
um yeah mango says there's a great
documentary about tim burton's attempt
to make superman with nicholas cage
that i need to see that i have a weird
feeling that it might have been good
it probably would have it probably would
have been batshit crazy which you know
that's always a plus i don't know if it
made money
but i think it might have been good
probably not i mean there's a there's a
fine line it's like sometimes you can
make [ __ ] batshit crazy and everybody's
like oh okay more of that please and
then sometimes you make something bad
[ __ ] crazy and i was like yeah no thank
you
you know what i mean so i feel like
beetlejuice hit that sweet spot
of being like weird as [ __ ] but also
everybody loved it yeah um but if it had
gone like a little too much in either
direction
it's like i don't think it would have
succeeded now heat going back to heat
it was a good movie i liked it it had a
really good score
really good score um the way things were
shot
were really good the move the movie i
think is 96 95
95 when it came out end of 95. you can
see
how it's kind of like to be the way it
shot it's like the beginning of a new
era
the way it's shot still holds up today
i can see that a lot of modern movies
sometimes they almost seem like they're
direct descendants of this movie
but there are certain things that it
does are very old
school which i think works like there's
there's green screen in it
uh i don't know if you noticed it but
jimmy and jenny noticed it
when um de niro and his girlfriend uh
they're out there on the balcony over
the skyline
talking to each other it's like a
romance scene and you see the damn
i guess it's the california or the los
angeles
[ __ ] skyline um the horizon there at
night with all the city lights
it looked really good it didn't look
real though yeah it's obviously green
screen
and you go like that shit's too perfect
that's not the way that city looks
you know what i mean uh in real life it
just looked great you know what i mean
well it's like heightened reality yeah
like a heightened reality shots and yeah
and uh i don't think anybody would have
thought i don't think a modern
director would have even thought to do
something like that today
maybe the interesting thing about heat
is that even though it was made in the
mid 90s it doesn't scream
90s no no there's nothing like even
the clothes people are wearing and stuff
like that it's just to me it really
didn't seem
it had like a timeless quality to it
yeah you could have told me that that
was like 2005 and i would have been okay
yeah i mean other than the cell phones
but you didn't really see much of that
yeah you know what i mean none of that
none of the hair was dated
yeah the clothes were dated none of the
vehicles were all that dated except the
[ __ ] vehicles that they were going to
sacrifice during those crimes
yeah and then you see little what's her
name and she's only like 13 or 14 and
you're like man this movie was a long
time ago what's her name um
natalie natalie portman natalie i forgot
pull her ass out of the damn bathtub
she'd slit her wrists and [ __ ] you look
at her and you go like man that's like a
little girl
yeah she was little yeah well it was how
old how old was she she was only 14 or
15 i think she was like 14 which yeah
that movie and she's little to begin
with yeah
she's a tiny tiny person you're right i
mean she just looks like a child
um but it's funny we saw a movie her in
the theater
ways back where she played some rock
star remember that was the [ __ ]
box lux fox yeah that's right that was a
[ __ ] wild ass weird
it's really weird because that movie
just seemed like it came and went like
disappeared and like nobody remembers it
i liked it though i feel like we were
probably the only ones that saw it it
was a [ __ ] you movie
i guess it was it was a [ __ ]
it was a [ __ ] you movie about [ __ ] about
it was like a big criticism of celebrity
yeah and people who are famous and then
and and the entertainment industry so of
course
of course it just came and went they
didn't really i think it was based on a
novel too which might be
like might be worth reading it was a big
[ __ ] you to celebrities
which she has some balls for doing that
almost like a protest
well she i mean natalie portman uh to
give her her prop she's been in like a
couple of kind of not great movies but
she's actually willing to go out there
and do some weird [ __ ] man i mean she
was in
annihilation she was in um what was that
[ __ ]
thing that i just thought of five
seconds ago and then it just went flying
right out of my head
i don't know i got the feeling she's
kind of like on somebody's
black swan that's what i was thinking of
yeah darren aronofsky
i got the feeling that she's on
somebody's [ __ ] list i think she's kind
of like on the outs in the hollywood
scene
probably wouldn't [ __ ] some dude and you
know or threaten to tell on some dude or
something and
because you know they they haven't
really
said much about her and they haven't
tried to [ __ ] put her up front and
get her to be in movies that maybe she's
just not a draw like she used to be
i don't know yeah maybe not and like i
said it's
you know she just seems like one of
those people yeah black swan a bunch of
people said i said i don't think you've
seen that i've seen it a couple of times
um it's pretty weird it's it's a horror
movie i guess but it's kind of like a
a strange horror movie she plays like a
ballet dancer she's probably got [ __ ]
you money so they don't want to deal
with her
i mean that's the thing once you make
like a couple of successful movies and
she was in some
she was in the star wars prequels she
probably got all the money for that so
she was just like [ __ ] i'm just going
to do whatever the [ __ ] i want yeah
i mean that's what i would do yeah i'm
just going to be in movies i want to be
in
yeah so it's difficult to control a
person that has [ __ ] you money
yeah you know um but yeah i wanna
i was gonna say too that michael mann
the same guy that directed heat
he also did um manhunter
which is the first uh hannibal elector
maybe yeah and he did
uh the insider which was also really
good i think i saw that in the theater
too
also he did miami vice did you know that
yeah he did the tv show
and he did a movie based on it but i
didn't see the movie uh collateral he
did that too
last of the mohicans so you know
he does all those he he's really into
like crime movies
she was saying that padme was awful
stiff that
the prequels basically sucked and
yeah she sucked in that but i don't
think it was her fault it's because
the dialogue was so bad in that movie
the writing was
they were bad in all three of those
movies
lucas is a good idea man you don't
really want him as a director right and
you don't want him you don't want him to
have the final say in anything step away
from the script
[Laughter]
step away from the [ __ ] jar jar
he likes to put [ __ ] goofy [ __ ] in
movies and
well it's our kids ball man shut the
[ __ ] up dude that's not who's
paying the bills you know i mean it's
just
although look here's the thing lucas
gets [ __ ] on a lot
for some of the mistakes he made with
these
properties that he created but
he doesn't get the credit that he
deserves in terms of [ __ ] all the
technological advancement his companies
did
digital cameras digital editing [ __ ]
all this [ __ ]
great [ __ ] industrial what's what's name
what's the name of that company
yeah that [ __ ] basically
they basically invented modern [ __ ]
cinema technology in that company
you know so he was extremely innovative
just he backed and funded all the
[ __ ]
technological innovations that people
just take for granted today so he
he was [ __ ] a badass when it came to
a lot of cinematic
innovation you know um i just didn't
agree with all of his
their direction in his i don't know how
he directed star wars and yeah i mean
you know you can't be good at it he's
not gonna
be good at everything you know his he
was a real good idea man
movies are a collaborative right but he
didn't collaborate
now the original the original ones
especially uh star wars and empire
strikes back where he was
he was there but he didn't have a whole
lot of control those are the best movies
especially empire strikes back
that's because they had some veteran
guys that knew how to [ __ ] make
world war ii movies and [ __ ] and it gave
you a [ __ ]
really good traditional
war movie that's what [ __ ] empire
strikes what empire strikes back was
that's why it worked it was like you
were watching a classic movie from the
40s
that's the tone of star wars yeah and
empire
in return to the jet what is it return
of the jedi
it's he has a lot more control than that
he did some goofy [ __ ] in that movie
but it still turned out okay
you could you could edit the movie into
something a little bit better like
why does c3po and rtg2 fall off the sand
barge and hit the sand and stick into it
their feet sticking up
you know what i mean just to have the
[ __ ] just to have them pulled out in
a funny scene that's just dumb [ __ ]
boba fett falls in the sarlock pit and
it burps that's just dumb [ __ ]
you got the little salacious crumb thing
going you know i'm [ __ ] making
there's too much of that [ __ ] in there
too much a [ __ ] goofy kitty [ __ ]
yeah you know quit making movies for
kids goddammit
little ewoks you know they're fighting
and dying and it's got goofy [ __ ]
ewok music in there which they
they fixed later they made it less fun
well the thing about it is that the
ewoks can be cute but they're also like
little people
and they were they were fighting and
they were getting killed like that's not
funny
yeah they changed it though they put
more serious music later on in
in that end scene which totally changed
kick ass teddy bear
yeah where they totally changed it so
where they weren't funny
anymore you know yeah when they were
dying it's like that's trying to figure
out that's not funny when little living
teddy bears get killed
that's that's really really sad and
they're super brave
so yeah i so i didn't really realize
what the what the one i wanted and the
ewoks were cash grabbed to begin with
because
yeah originally they were going to be
wookies not ewoks
yeah but you didn't have [ __ ] money
it's like well wookies aren't cute
enough
right we can't
yeah they could all fight together
wookies with ewoks on their shoulders
yeah yeah you could have wookies and
ewoks on the same planet
and they're like cousins yeah yeah and
they had like the master blaster thing
like you said
the wookie the ewoks are on the back of
the wall yeah because they're little and
wookies are big
yeah so it's like they're kind of like
in in this kind of like relationship
where it's like symbiotic you know
yeah i could see that yeah these call me
hurts lucas call me the e-watch
on the shoulders with [ __ ] bows and
arrows yeah yeah that's what i was
that's what i was thinking they're
shooting stuff while the [ __ ]
wookie's [ __ ] using damn that's what
i was thinking so it's like a two-prong
it's a two-pronged attack it's like a
tank
tank and he walks a turret turn on come
on come on george lucas
well cheap-ish not that cheap but you
know you've got money come on
call me
[Laughter]
serpent server says [ __ ] cute i want arm
tearing roided up wookies
i said christian haydenson was [ __ ]
awful in those films hey and christensen
he was a christian as you know he was
yeah
uh yeah i think that's the dialogue
though what they gave him to do
hard to work with any of that [ __ ] and
lucas can't write dialogue nobody talks
like that
no let me uh let me get you to the train
something that i was just
that just occurred to me is that
i hate well i guess i hate to like [ __ ]
on actors until you've seen them in a
wide range of things because look at
like hayden christensen or look at
um here's a better example look at uh
kristen stewart and robert pattinson
from the twilight movies twilight movies
were awful
um and they were pretty awful in them
but when you see them in other things
they're awesome so that just goes to
show
that it's not that they're shitty actors
it's just that
you know the script is perhaps shitty or
the director was perhaps shitty to them
wasn't bringing out the best maybe the
edit is bad and is making them look
like they're not great actors and [ __ ]
like that i mean twilight i know that's
probably like the source material
because that's like some
terrible terrible [ __ ] and honestly it's
kind of like
this is another thing that makes me mad
like also as a writer
is that you know stephanie meyer
the chick that wrote the twilight books
the books are just
they're not good they're just like badly
written it's like there's all kind of
like really questionable [ __ ] going on
in there
and the fact that i mean i don't know i
guess i can't judge because people did
enjoy them and people obviously paid
money for them and she made pretty much
all the money in the world that jk
rowling didn't already make
um so you know you can't [ __ ] on her too
much because i guess people
liked it but i don't know it just makes
me mad and like sometimes i feel like
why even bother like trying to
write anything good if people are just
gonna like buy a bunch of shitty crap
like that
you know what i mean it's like but even
if i tried to write something shitty i
don't even know if i could
okay yeah i was like what are you doing
that's not mine
so oh you didn't put granite in that at
this time no just kidding like it's not
pink
just lemon let me give you choice
that's good yeah what's funny about
the prequels talk about [ __ ] star
wars
the prequels um
somebody took all three of those movies
and pulled them apart
using computers and re-edited them
yeah i watched those the fan edits
they're they're great yeah and they
re-edit it into two movies
the three movies into two and evidently
it's a lot better
i want i don't know if i watched the
whole thing but i kind of i did kind of
went go through and sample like oh
because i was curious
and i was just kind of like see now
editors are like the unknown heroes of
hollywood
yeah you need a good one because they
need to know definitely the flow of the
story and it still makes sense and
everything a certain whole
i think certain plot threads are just
dropped because you don't need that
and it's just re the three movies
re-entered it into two movies
a lot better i mean i kind of feel like
if you're making a movie i know that
they make like big epic [ __ ] you can get
away with [ __ ] in books that you can't
get away with in movies and we've talked
about that before
i feel like if you're making a movie um
main plot no more than two side plots
okay you have like
more than two side plots you just knock
that [ __ ] off you need to like cut some
[ __ ] out
because you know how you know what
happens they have like the main plot you
have all this [ __ ] going on the sides
then you have like some other [ __ ] you
introduce and then they like forget
about it
so it's like what even happened to that
person we don't know i see it happen all
the time it's like it's just it's just
really sloppy you need to like keep [ __ ]
focused
serpent surfer he's second getting into
the same [ __ ]
that i was talking about i'm gonna read
what he says he says also the way anakin
was portrayed in the sequels is not how
ben described him in the first one he
was supposed to be a badass war buddy
and instead was an emo edgelord oh yeah
yeah okay well
years back i was [ __ ] bitching to
jenny
describing how how that whole thing
should have gone and it should have gone
the way like you said
the way ben described it well i mean all
they had to do was go back and watch
those movies right
and take notes there's a bunch of stuff
that would have only taken a couple of
hours bunch of stuff wrong
with the anakin character first of all
he should have been the best jedi that
they had
okay he from the
this isn't anything to do with how he
was with the force or everything he
should have been the best jedi
that they had and he should have been
pretty old when this happened
in his 30s he should have gotten
involved in a civil war remember i told
you
yeah where you couldn't tell who the
good guys and who the bad guys were that
they were
basically they both thought the other
side was the enemy
and they didn't and they didn't know why
but they had proof that the other side
was the enemy
then they they they kill each other and
then it turns out later on
that anakin realizes that the guys he
was killing were actually right were the
good guys
they were the good guys and he was the
war that he was waging against the jedi
was done to him through basically
because through lies and
just lies and propaganda that came from
a
sith master that he didn't even know
existed
and then that sith master was should
have said you should have known that i
was lying to you you're
supposed to be the [ __ ] beth so it's
on you you
deep down you knew that kind of [ __ ] and
get him to [ __ ]
hate himself and turn in on himself and
he should have
he actually should have killed padme and
then turned out he was wrong
you know what i mean yeah he should have
thought padme was a sith
something like that and that she was
lying and then it would have made all
made a lot more sense that he hunted
down the jedi
yeah see it's like that just would tie
up so many
loose motivations and then once he
hunted down the jedi and killed him and
then once he said well you know what
if that was the jedi
they were weak they should have been
stronger
you know what i mean that that that's
how he could have justified
turning to the dark side yeah you know
because to me it just seemed to
it seemed too easy right he seemed so
kind of wishy-washy
and then it's like it would take a lot
to
turn somebody that was really really
good into a bad person but it could be
done but like you said it would have to
be done through manipulation yeah
um and you know misleading them and
using their good intentions against them
and i feel like that's kind of like a
missed opportunity and then once you get
down
into the sith path anakin realizes that
morality is just narrative and
interpretation of narrative
so then he can justify it to himself
yeah what i mean
says like yeah i was fooled but i was
fooled because i was weak at that time i
was a jedi
had i been a sith i wouldn't have been
able they couldn't have fooled me
but now i know you know and the the the
the jedi that i killed that was on them
because they were too weak to stop me
yeah you could totally see how that
right i mean most people would be able
to see
like how we got from a to b yeah it
should have been me killing padme was my
punishment for being weak
had i been a sith i would have seen that
it was inception
yes that's but you see the guys that
write this [ __ ] have never lived
anything like that
you know i mean they're kind of pampered
in a certain way they're living out in
l.a
hookers and blow they believe in [ __ ]
right and wrong and black and white and
they've never [ __ ]
gone to any [ __ ] war or anything so
they've never they've never had personal
moral confusion
you know so they don't know how to
resolve things like that they can't
write like that because they don't think
like that
because that's how that's how a
psychopath thinks
but that's psychopaths survive that kind
of [ __ ] though they don't even have
[ __ ] stress
but the thing about it though is that as
a writer you should kind of be able to
put yourself
into that mind right right i mean
because like i said
i told you um you know i write horror
obviously and uh
my mom like read some of my short
stories and i think when she read some
of them she was kind of horrified
because she
thought that i was
drawing from real life or from my real
thoughts or something like that i'm like
no it's like it's called imagination
like being able to put yourself
into someone else's shoes or into
someone else's mindset even if they're a
horrible evil person if i was this
person
what would justify my actions
and that's all you have to do really you
don't have to be a terrible person
yourself you just have to be able to
like
put yourself into someone else's mindset
and understand where they're coming from
that's all and that's what makes like
really good characters
being able to put your put yourself into
other people's even if you don't agree
and actually
it is harder because i have written
characters that were just horrible
people that were nothing like me
but you know it is a lot more difficult
it's much easier to write somebody
that's
obviously just like like yourself but
you know
that's it would be pretty boring if all
you wrote was
just a bunch of characters that were
just like they were just like me all the
time
you know what i'm saying yeah but yeah
so
but yeah so what was what was i saying
oh yeah but uh
yeah i don't really i don't really know
what she was talking about that
palpatine was
anakin's groomed by palpatine yeah of
course that's pretty obvious
it's just that the way that [ __ ] really
should have gone down it should have
been a lot more realistic
um that anakin
anakin should have [ __ ] ended up kind
of being tricked into murdering the
[ __ ] jedi thinking that they were
bad okay and then he blaming himself for
being a jedi he didn't see the [ __ ]
deception
then he realizes the strength and the
power you get from being a [ __ ] sith
all right and that the jedi deserved
what they got so there's all kinds of
[ __ ] victim blaming
and stuff okay that you have to do into
this that's what they would call it
today
but what what you're really talking
about is stuff that goes on in kind of
like
nichian philosophy and stuff that
happens in
machiavellian [ __ ] thinking so you
should have ended up being just real
machiavellian
um very um
uh very much a part of power and
authority uh
it should have been all for bringing
peace
into the [ __ ] into the galaxy
because democracies and republics are
about endless strife
and endless disagreement the empire was
just
bringing all that to the end so you have
peace and security
and uh you listen to what we say we blow
your [ __ ] planet up
you can vote for your own planetary
governor
do whatever you want just give us your
[ __ ] cut
send us the money every month to get out
of line we blow you up
which that's what the idea was but it
wasn't expressed too well
in those three movies yeah that's all
what there were some it was the kernels
of good ideas
in there it's just i feel like they
focused on the wrong things that's all
yeah vader would have seen himself as a
professional bringing peace to the
galaxy
because everything well he does kind of
say that in the originals he says
we need to stop this [ __ ] endless
conflict
yeah we're just going to make everybody
like do what we want
it's the peace [ __ ] robert plant is
singing about
in the immigrant song with the vikings
coming to [ __ ]
they're coming with the tides of war to
[ __ ] bring peace to your land
because they're going to be your
overlords and uh you know
step out of line they're getting yeah
that should have been it should have
been some [ __ ]
in spite of all you're losing [ __ ] like
that you know
so it's everything on how you spin that
narrative
yeah um was anakin goth or just emo
i vote for emo yeah he didn't look gothy
he didn't listen any cool [ __ ] gods
wouldn't be whining like that
that's some emo [ __ ] i feel like i feel
like goths get
got a reputation once everybody knew
what it was because like i said we grew
up a lot of people there were some good
ideas there
you know he finds his mom
after all that time and she was being
tortured by the sand people so he killed
all the same people and he couldn't save
her life that was a good idea
yeah um it was just some of the other
stuff
the way he was acting around padme you
know what i mean the [ __ ] the romance
between her and padme wasn't real
credible
it didn't i didn't really feel anything
there you know yeah there wasn't they
didn't they just didn't have a lot of
chemistry with one another
um which they should have minimized a
lot of that
they should have the whole thing about
the
politics going on in the [ __ ] senate
was kind of
kind of a waste of time yeah that didn't
need to be in there yeah i mean they
could have just
truncated that a lot have you guys heard
of the september 1982 investor massacre
at craig arkansas i have not actually uh
mike barrett what do you think is the
best star wars prequel if any uh
the third one yeah yeah yeah venue
equally
yeah that would actually was pretty good
yeah revenge of the sith is pretty good
although maybe i'm just thinking that
because the first two were so [ __ ] and
the first
the not that bad it's just that
there was problems with jar jar binks
was
shouldn't have been in the movies um
it was a lot of the problems with the
first two was edit
yeah edit and the focus of the movie i
really liked uh that they had
christopher lee in there
as [ __ ] doku and some of the [ __ ]
that they did they had a real good
character that
uh multi-armed guy what was his [ __ ]
name
grievous grievous yeah dude that was but
the thing is they kind of had
comic in overtones with with with
with grievous and they didn't use that
character
enough and it shouldn't have been a cgi
character it should have been cg
really in any of this [ __ ] except maybe
the backgrounds
everything that would have been
acceptable yeah it should have been
because i don't
i didn't didn't get the feeling that
grievous was there it just looks like a
[ __ ] comic but
it looks like well everything looked
like a cartoon a video game cut scene
that's
what annoyed me and also the thing too
is that i kind of feel like you know in
the first
um you know in star wars empire strikes
back there is humor in there yeah
but i don't know like the humor in those
seems a lot more organic or it
comes out of the situation whereas i
feel like in the later ones they were
trying to force in humor because it's
like hey we need some funny [ __ ] right
here and it's like it really didn't need
to be in there
i'm not saying you had to make the movie
like really dire and serious and
everything you could have put some
levity in there
but i just i felt like they should do it
like in a more organic fashion rather
than trying to like kind of shoehorn it
it seemed a little shoehorned i'm just
saying yeah you know what i mean
there was just um what was his name
[ __ ] grievous should have been a
[ __ ] puppet
or like a uh like a marionette they had
the technology to where you could
build three or four of those things like
legs or a feet or a head
and splice it all together where that
thing could have moved
man they've done it before but they've
done it in older movies than
that one it's basically the term new
yeah you know
you just do a better version of like the
truth i would rather see stop motion
than see cgi to be honest with you you
could have made something that was
really there and it didn't have to be
something that was going around doing
all these [ __ ]
you know he rolled into a ball and then
got in a [ __ ] motor
hey you know they were showing you
something new but none of that is
believable well it doesn't it's not
didn't look real and it didn't
it didn't serve the story in any
capacity no they were just showing off
just showing off what they didn't do
with cg that's just a stupid
grievous should have been a robot just
like any other
any other robots from the original
trilogies he could have looked just like
that but just been a big [ __ ] puppet
it's like save it for your resume reel
[ __ ] don't put it in the movie
it looks a lot more classic and it and
it didn't have that used
that used look that the originals had
the originals everything looked beat up
see that's what i liked about the first
ones is that everything looked like
it had been in use for like a really
long time like people actually used the
[ __ ] and yeah
you know we dug this out of the you know
junkyard and we kind of
cobbled it together into something that
worked and the interior of the
spaceships were interiors
you could tell that that was something
that really existed yeah the interiors a
lot of those spaceships
looked like a cg background to me just
dumb that's what i mean it just looked
like a
it just looked like a cartoon it didn't
look like it didn't have it's very
soulless looking it just kind of looked
like a video game yeah generic generic
solos which kind of bums me out i mean
it didn't really have any character
i feel like if you're gonna make a
sci-fi movie like that i mean the
backgrounds
should have character and should you
know
contribute to the story like there
should be [ __ ] you don't notice it but
there should be [ __ ] going on in the
background that like kind of
you know fills in the world without you
even realizing it you know what i'm
saying and it's like it
just really wasn't doing that because
they're just like we just want to make
this look super cool in the background
and blah blah that's
i don't know i like i said i that's why
i don't
hate cgi um you know
just completely because obviously it can
be used for things it's a tool just like
everything else
for backgrounds but yeah i think it's
better when they use it for backgrounds
or when they just use it to kind of
clean up
cover up entire tracks and stuff yeah or
like you know take out wires like they
did in mad max fury road or something
like that it's like most of the time
they should just do real [ __ ] it just
looks
better it's just you know i'm sorry it
just does you can tell that that [ __ ] is
not there
yeah and it's you know and all i can
think when i see movies like that
is that all i can all i can think of is
the actor in a green screen room staring
at a tennis ball
that's all i think of every single time
i see a boobie that's cgi heavy like
that
it just and it just takes me right out
of it
uh gram there's hammer asked are people
born goth or do they find it like one
finds religion
[Laughter]
that's actually a good question kind of
grow up in it it's your friends
i mean for us it started off with
friends in high school
to me i i don't know to me it almost
seemed
genetic in a way because even before i
knew what that
was like when i was a little kid in the
70s like before i had discovered it
ever since i can remember ever since i
first learned to read when i was really
small
all i wanted to read about was ghosts
and witches and scary [ __ ] i love scary
[ __ ]
so like any time that anything scary was
on people was it adam's family or
whether it was
you know a show that's like their
halloween episode i was super super into
it and i was like super into
anything creepy anything into horror
movies anything like that
i always wanted to watch it and that was
kind of like
as far back as i can remember before i
even knew that was so it's like i was
really into it
and then i it's weird because i think
in you know the real early 80s i was
watching
i don't even think it was mtv i think it
was a night flight or one of those old
like video shows that they used to have
on cable
and i saw a cure video um
i can't remember which one it was it was
the walk why did that come out 82 83
something like that so i was only like
10 or 11.
and i saw it and i was like oh my god
there are other people that are into the
same kind of [ __ ] like i fell in love
with it immediately
so i just thought it was so because i
just thought you know i grew up in
daytona beach there was nobody
that was into that kind of [ __ ] really
like you know when i was a little kid
everybody was just in a normal [ __ ] or
they were into like rednecky [ __ ]
so i was just kind of like i thought i
was the only person and like i was a
weirdo
so it's like when i saw a cure video i
was super jazzed i was like oh my god
there's other people that like all this
creepy [ __ ] and
they you know they like all this you
know darkness and having like big hair
and like all
and i was like really really excited to
like find that out and i think that that
was
so that was probably like the first i
had been kind of into new wave before
that
like i was really into duran duran i was
real into
um modern english i was real into
psychedelic furs
the police like all that kind of stuff
like from
real young so it was so that was just
kind of like a progression from that i
was just really excited that there was
this whole thing
where other people were into like creepy
ass [ __ ] and like
creepy sounding music because i was just
kind of like oh
well this is these are obviously my
people i need to go over here with this
so that's why i always kind of tell
people it's funny because
my parents were real they weren't you
know my parents were very chill and they
were just kind of like yeah you know we
don't get it but whatever just do
whatever you want
so they never got on my case about you
know dressing weird or anything
or you're piercing what um you know they
didn't do that
but i think deep down they thought that
at some point
i was going to grow out of it you know
what i mean and some people do
um i think especially later on
i don't know i cuz i kind of feel like
people that grew up with it maybe in the
70s and 80s
it's it was more like just trying things
out
yeah it was more that was almost kind of
like a more part of your identity
because it was kind of newer
and you know it was exciting that you
found people with you know similar
interests to you
i feel like once it kind of went
mainstream like in the 90s
you know when there was all the [ __ ]
movies you know the crow and all that
kind of stuff like the matrix
when it kind of went like that i feel
like it became more of a thing
that um you know teenagers would
do it's like a phase you know what i
mean not everybody obviously
but i feel like that was less of a thing
you're looking at it from the viewpoint
of like a high school student though
well yeah for for me
when i was in high school there was goth
stuff that i would list to listen to
and a lot of the girls i was dating and
me and steve were dating over in
in michigan they were like goth adjacent
but god wasn't a thing
you know we call them little punkers
little punk rock girls yeah it really
goth wasn't really a cogent thing until
maybe
yeah and everybody had a different kind
of looks but they were just all the
kids that were had you know were in
bands or in the drama
drama class and you know they were
[ __ ] for us they were just like the
cool kids they were your friends
and then uh in brazil i was you know i
was listening to music that ended up
being called goth like sisters of mercy
and stuff and bauhaus
and skinny puppy which is like got the
industrial
i listened to all that kind of stuff in
brazil and then came back to united
states and i was out of high school and
then you end up just going to
clubs where your friends go and there's
the same ones yeah you know
in in in detroit was you know city club
and
[ __ ] um you know what was the other
one called sanders hall which was
[ __ ]
and then there was uh what was that
other one we used to go to the shelter
and it was like a something out of blade
runner you know so brazil
or [ __ ] detroit was all
post-apocalyptic looking at that time
you know
so i didn't really have a sense of being
in a goth scene
until later on when i got out of the
army then when i got out of the army
moved to boston him one of the best golf
clubs in the [ __ ] world called man
ray
and um that by that time it was called
goth
yeah because when i was growing up then
they went to
it was just my friends you know what i
mean yeah
and hanging out in these [ __ ] bizarre
ass [ __ ] clubs
so it was for me it was more of a club
culture than a high school thing because
it didn't exist when i was in high
school
i mean i was in i call it that i was in
high school you know because i'm a
couple years younger than you
yeah um when i was in high school like i
said i got into
new wave and [ __ ] like that when i was
probably yeah
in junior high like earlier and then i
started getting into darker [ __ ] like
when i was still in junior high um
and in high school i just started
hanging out with
like you said there was people that were
into everything like i liked like all
the you know geeky people that were kind
of like in the math club and the chess
club and all that you got all the band
people
and then you had you know dudes that
were into
you know uh punk rock and you had people
that were in the sky
you had people that were so and
everybody just kind of hung out together
if you liked weird music
yeah because where i went to high school
was
very upper middle class and it was right
on the beach
so i mean literally right across from
the street from the beach my
uh was from daytona beach my high school
was i went to seabreeze
and um so a lot of the people that went
there it was a very
you know tan bleach blonde jock kind of
you know that so
80 90 of the school was that um
so if you liked weird [ __ ] there was
only like
12 of us and we all kind of hung out
together
you know and we liked a lot of the same
stuff like our interests overlapped but
a lot of
our stuff was like kind of different too
you know what i mean yeah
but um serpents [ __ ] laughing going
yeah skinny puppy he like talked about
remission
yeah bites in remission that was good
when i was hanging out in detroit
i used to see skinny puppy come in there
all the time saw him play a couple times
there i think it was a i think it was
sandra's hall then they were showing up
at like the shelter and stuff
afterwards and i used to see them and be
like man
[ __ ] they weren't that famous then
they were just a local band you know
i was like man that motherfucker's got
some [ __ ] badass boots and i'm just
thinking
because back in those days it was hard
to get those kind of clothes yeah
somebody like
thorne was just saying i got my clothes
from thrift shops yeah it's like we i
went to thrift shops in like army navy
store
yeah and kevin key was wearing [ __ ]
those boots and he had fish nets on
black fishnets that's the first time i
ever saw that that was uh
maybe 1987 88
around that time no 88 1988 around that
time 89
he hit those [ __ ] fish nets on i
didn't see that later until like trent
resner with that [ __ ]
he's wearing fishnets and i was going
like man that looks [ __ ] badass
i was and i remember thinking where did
he get those
like did he go to the women's section to
get those or do they make
men's fishnets well peterborough peter
murphy used to wear them and daniel ash
used to wear them back in but i really
hated them
i didn't see them yeah it was the first
time i saw it you know
and uh that's the first time i remember
seeing it they
he had those things on and uh i was my
mind was blown
it was just a different time you know
matter of fact one of our regulars
worked for skinny puppy who was that
oh yeah i remember somebody said that
who was that i don't remember now i
forgot who it was you might be in
it might be in this comment section
right now so we got we got
serpent we got some people in the in the
comments right now
in the chat probably yeah thorn says too
had to use sharpies to paint your nails
black yep i remember that
uh and black island make lipstick i
remember
every halloween would come around and
they would have like all that real cheap
jack
like black lipstick that was only time
you could get it uh
right around halloween that like dollar
lipstick and it was like
super shitty it's like you had to put
like tons of it on because it was just
like all
oil yeah and uh that was the only time
you could get like black lipstick or
anything was like right around halloween
so i would buy like a whole bunch of it
and then like save it up for all year
late 80s late 80s i was a andrew
eldridge
billy idol type of goth yeah i said
[ __ ] black jeans engineer boots
[ __ ] black
uh leather jack motorcycle jacket
[ __ ] black
concert shirts long black hair you know
round [ __ ] black spectacles [ __ ] like
that just left it like that remember
those spectacles yeah i had some of
those yeah little little round speckles
they had the [ __ ] little side
yeah visor yeah i had some of them yeah
i had some of those and uh
then i went to the army when i came back
everything [ __ ] had changed
then it was all kind of vampiric and all
like [ __ ] the stat and [ __ ]
1800s and 1700s was like the that was
like the top [ __ ] when it
came out yeah everything went very
edwardian edwardian and [ __ ] yeah so
i headed up my game
i had to up my game i like both of those
looks and actually i like a combo of
those looks i like kind of like the
the victorian edwardian thing with like
the corsets and everything but then i
like
it you know interposed with real death
rocky [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean um because i
always
really really liked that that death rock
kind of looked that goth punk
uh takeover like i said and i think i've
brought this up before but
several years ago [ __ ] man i can't
remember what it was no
2000 what look at serpent he's in there
recommended i
really recommend clans fold manipulate
that's a good album
yeah that's got bert with water on it
remember that
that's [ __ ] yeah yeah just just you
know
[ __ ] servant are you are you really a
black dude or is that are you just
you just trolling with that [ __ ] um
icon not many black dudes know that
[ __ ] band i think we know
two here that would be uh no what
um tom would know that one and uh
so would uh walker and what about lee
yeah elite would know so that's three
three you know i know
i know three black dudes that would know
that yeah yeah and thorn says i made my
fishnet shirts from fishnet pantyhose
yeah i remember doing that cutting the
crotches out and then like you pulled
the like you don't wear them you just
bought
fishnet and then like yeah you cut the
feet off and you cut the crotch out and
then hugo was going my crew used black
fish and that's back in 82 yes they did
they were also wearing their
girlfriend's [ __ ] clothing
well yeah and i was thinking the goddamn
same thing where'd that [ __ ] get
those pants
he got that from the girls section his
girlfriend well yeah
but you weren't thinking that way in
[ __ ] 84 or 85 when you said
i feel like i didn't realize that they
were cross-dressing i was too young to
[ __ ] make that leap
the 70s and 80s don't get enough credit
yeah
for kind of normalizing
um you know gender bending yeah i mean
the 80s that was very big
yeah especially like all the new
romantic [ __ ] and then like you look at
you had
eurythmics you had like annie lennox
like wearing men's clothes
buzzed off hair and you know look at
like you know boy george and like i said
all the new romantic stuff very early
duran duran where they were wearing like
real fancy
kind of [ __ ] they had all the makeup on
and everything with earrings and
all that like they kind of looked like
pirates and [ __ ] that first motley crew
album too fast for love that had a very
gothic look
very gothic for that time a lot of the
[ __ ] goth
bands ended up looking kind of like that
like you'd see specimen and [ __ ] kind of
look like that and [ __ ]
especially aliens sex
yeah i'm a big death rock fan i really
like a lot of
rock [ __ ] i like a lot of that death
right lower to the new church all that
of
things yeah well even there were even
like a few good
um [ __ ] man there were even a few good
death rock bands
just going back a few years because i i
feel like
for in the early 2000 early to mid 2000s
there was a little bit of a mini
death rock revival because what i was
going to say was that they had a death
rock festival called the drop dead
festival that was in new york city a
couple years in a row and i went to it
and you know they had bands like cinema
strange who i really like
um they also have like a side band
called the dead fly ensemble who are
more like experimental
um you know and you had just like all
these really cool what's that other
[ __ ] band that i'm thinking of they
were german
and i don't know i'll think of it in a
minute but um yeah so there were a lot
of
really cool bands like floating around
around that time
um but i i don't know i i really really
liked that
look but there's a very subtle
difference though
between you know if you look at somebody
like johnny [ __ ]
you know from specimen um and somebody
from
you know kind of an early 80s you know
early 80s motley crew for example
it's similar but it's not exactly
the same yeah and i gotta [ __ ] go
back on hugo mustard
yeah [ __ ] motley crew might have been
[ __ ] around with that
in 82 but motley crue wasn't famous in
82. maliku didn't get famous until the
shot of the devil album came out
and then all of a sudden their back
catalog started [ __ ] selling
you know in 82 i was still in military
school
no i know yeah i was just coming out i
think i might have just been coming out
and going brazil at that time
well but you know you had goth bands
that were wearing that
by 85-86 well like a couple years later
well bauhaus were wearing that
in 1980 1981
um also i will i think lou reed was
wearing that yeah
before that and he was also wearing like
black well because
that and the [ __ ] new york dolls and
[ __ ] they're probably well yeah if you
go back to the new york dolls that was
like early 70s
because i mean you know goth was really
really influenced by glam rock in a lot
of ways
and glam rock but everything was black
that's the only difference black or red
yeah and particularly bauhaus because
they took a lot of cues from
glam rock also reggae they were they had
a lot of reggae influence
um you know obviously really into bowie
and velvet underground and [ __ ] like
that
but they took um you know they took a
lot of influence from a lot of different
kind of [ __ ] but yeah like you said it a
lot of the early goth and death rock
look was just glam rock well gender
bending is just kind of natural it's
artsy and creative
not only that these dudes are broke and
their girlfriends were giving them their
clothes
and the makeup the girlfriends were the
ones doing all the hair and the makeup
and all those bands
well yeah because they're like you look
cool well they they did look cool
yeah [ __ ] nikki six and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] vince neil were stealing their
girlfriend's clothes to wear on stage
that was their girlfriend's clothes
they couldn't afford their own [ __ ]
clothes but those dudes were [ __ ]
poor
real poor watch that [ __ ] documentary
about them
they say that's pretty close to the
truth the crazy [ __ ]
what was the name of that i think it was
just called the dirt the dirt yeah
it was based on that book yeah the dirt
yeah there was ghetto
well yeah and that's the thing and i
this is kind of one thing that i always
kind of um
you know thought about was that men's
clothes in general
are pretty boring i mean you know
women can get away with a lot more one
of the best golf clubs in the country
in the country right now would be the
castle that's in tampa florida
yeah that's one of the best ones that's
better than the clubs in new york and
i've been to the clubs in new york i
guess
well it hasn't been a long it hasn't i
haven't been it's been a long time since
2009 i think
i went 2010. i went with 2011 2012.
it was in new york and it was hey i
don't want to insult you [ __ ] people
in new york but
no it paled the outfits and the
locations pale
comparison to [ __ ] tampa tampa
i mean tampa's a lot nicer when i went
to a lot better
when i went to the drop dead festival
that wasn't at that was like at a
concert venue
that was called um the knitting factory
and it was it's three stories so there
was you know there was a there was a
dance floor up here there's a dance
floor there was so there's two stages
and there was like a dj on the bottom
floor
now that place was pretty cool but they
had all kind of stuff in there it wasn't
just
goth center hugo goes shout out the
devil came out in 83.
so what yeah so what it came out in 83
yeah i remember well here's one thing
that i remember from junior high
and when the [ __ ] was i in junior high
okay so i was in high school
i graduated from high school in 1990 so
i was there 87 88 so
prior to 87 i was in junior high 86 85
84.
um so when i was in junior high
the big rivalry at my junior high school
was motley crew fans
versus duran duran fan if you were into
new wave
and you know exemplified by duran duran
you could like under other [ __ ] too
dude i had a satin duran duran jacket
somebody gave it to me like for a
present it was beautiful it had like
a lick it was black it was a black satin
jacket
it was i'm come on i'm you know i do
have some style even when even back in
the
early 80s so it was a black satin jacket
but it just had like the logo on the
back you know you remember back in the
80s where they had that logo it was like
a d
and there was like a d kind of like that
like a shadow yeah it was a good one
yeah so it had that on the back like
with some checkerboard or some [ __ ]
and it really showed up hey yeah
um so yeah i had that and man i used to
get [ __ ] on all the time by the motley
crew fans because they were dicks
sophie's trying to come down in a couple
months okay
yeah that'd be fun yeah it's gonna get
it's it's gonna be cool around here soon
i think shit's going to i think the
clubs are going to start rolling again
here soon
well they they've been open for a while
yeah they were open it's just that they
haven't been real busy
but i think they will be in a couple of
months
this saturday we might go to mannequins
yeah we're gonna go to mannequins this
saturday we gotta [ __ ] get some video
of that [ __ ] and post it
we keep saying that but we're never
gonna we got i got this [ __ ] camera
right here well yeah i bought that
well i bought that and somebody said
like along like probably about an hour
ago
that you should make like a whole poopy
channel and we have thought about that
that was initially why i bought that
camera because i was going to make a
pookie channel
i was talking about getting a gopro and
putting that on my helmet and going for
a [ __ ] ride
take him take him for a ride with me on
one of the buells yeah see there you go
yeah you were just talking about that
the other day yeah i'll put the
scratches and [ __ ] drag some knees
for you people
put the camera take you out and [ __ ]
back
yeah i don't think they can they don't
think they can get me
for going too fast can he in retrospect
video posting videos or something well
in retrospect no
yeah i didn't think so because they
think they got to catch you well yeah
they got to catch you in the act yeah
that's kind of like a thing
thorne says i met john taylor in an
elevator he farted
that's an awesome story i actually i'm
so sad because
i never got to see this one of the great
regrets of my life i never got to see
duran duran live i really wish i would
have seen them
um back in the day particularly during
their heyday because i was super into
them
i was really really into them up until
probably like right like i bought
notorious i remember buying that that
was 87.
that came out on vinyl and that was a
great album but for some reason
they were going us in a slightly
different direction when notorious came
out or at least from my perception
and i think when the next album came out
which was
big thing did big thing come out out
right after notorious or like a year or
two
later yeah i kind of feel like big thing
wasn't that good and i bought it on
cassette and i remember only listening
to it a few times and i liked like a
couple songs on it but like some of it i
was just kind of like man this is just
not
it took me a long time to get to where i
could listen to that whole album
it's kind of very humdrum it is and i
just felt like they
i don't know i just felt like they're
early [ __ ] maybe it's just me
i felt like their early [ __ ] like had
such a it was the writing
it had such a style to it it had such a
and it was like mainstream
but also kind of had its own thing and
it was really distinctive
they had access to better songwriters
because i don't think yeah
they didn't they wrote part of parts of
those songs all you gotta do is listen
to the [ __ ] demos
the demos it looks to the demo too they
had good producers to a view to a kill
that was what they first came up with
and then somebody came in there and
rewrote it made it a lot better
well they had to make it sound cinematic
yeah i mean
those bands especially from that era and
a big band like
duran duran was a group effort that was
a [ __ ]
huge [ __ ] team of people so they're
not going to let
inferior writing [ __ ] you know make
it past
the damn crucible of [ __ ] you know
talking about
production and once they lost all that
support
yeah no i mean they could do pretty good
i mean their [ __ ] was still good but it
just
it didn't have that spark anymore yeah i
felt like
they did come back with [ __ ] ordinary
world and [ __ ] and it had some good
stuff on that album
but it never had that [ __ ] tightness
that it had
in the 80s yeah because the guys that
were involved in it
same thing with billy idol well yeah
like i said i think duran duran really
um
benefited by having good but i'm not
saying like all of them are talented and
they wrote their own songs and stuff but
i do feel like their producers really
punch their [ __ ] up yeah and serpent
surfer
just uh mentioned actually two of my
favorite duran duran songs new religion
nightboat
both of which are on my [ __ ] phone
right now
matter of fact yeah those are the
[ __ ] good songs i mean the first
first album is really good the whole the
first three albums
my favorite you know which was duran
duran
rio 7 and the ragged tiger serpent
serpent surfer is not black
he says that's michael jordan's pitcher
he's a pale redhead
oh my god all in there i can't even see
i just see this tiny yeah
look at this smiling i think he had a
tiny little like clothing
michael james i can't tell who it is
he's the michael jordan
someone's got to be you know um i'm
still laughing about the john taylor
farting in the elevator
what hey god damn it john taylor hold it
in
for it or did he take credit or did he
try to blame it
[Laughter]
i would lose a lot of respect for john
taylor if he tried to blame it on
somebody else
if he'd have been like message
sorry then i'd be like all right you're
cool but still though
don't fart in an elevator come on hold
that [ __ ] in
wait till you get out wait till you get
into your own room and then you can fart
all you want
but no one's in there but it's like
that's holy [ __ ] that's so funny
but yeah i really really wish because
man i was like so into them i had all
the [ __ ]
i had uh you remember that big videotape
arena
that was like that whole live show i had
that i had the big videotape with all
the
all their videos on it i had all that
[ __ ] and i used to watch it like all the
time just like relentlessly and even
when i was in junior high
my entire bedroom was
covered floor to ceiling actually was
going to say floor to ceiling but the
ceiling had [ __ ] on it too
so floor like all the way around duran
duran pictures
i used to buy those horrible teen
magazines i didn't give a [ __ ] about
like ralph macchio or anybody else
really um
but if duran duran was in there i was
buying that [ __ ] and i was like pulling
all the pictures out and like putting
them all over the [ __ ]
how long have we been streaming i'm
surprised we haven't lost this stream
yet
don't say anything always when i start
talking about something conscious
yeah well don't do it we're just talking
about duran duran there's ai listening
to the [ __ ] stream
there's ai [ __ ] voice recognition
yeah but like i said
if i ever say anything sideways these
[ __ ] [ __ ] but like i said
you always forget that when we're just
talking about random nothing [ __ ] and it
just shuts off
don't question my my perspective on
[ __ ] reality
all right don't question even if it's
wrong that's not wrong i've seen it
happen to other
other other dudes i'm listening to the
stream and whenever they start talking
[ __ ] serious [ __ ]
about on certain [ __ ] subjects all of
a sudden they start losing bandwidth and
then they they start kicking people off
and they tried to [ __ ] choke the
[ __ ] stream down and then they lose
it
yeah and it's not a person doing it it's
an ai algorithm
and evidently it can even read the
comments in the comment section
and the ai will [ __ ] start to
everyone slowly shut it down
everyone's watching you so hi thorn said
thorne says he blamed it on his shoe
squeaking lame
john taylor own that [ __ ] we weren't
there man we didn't witness it
but that's pretty funny though yeah
fourth throw down says and japan left
them all in the dust yes but
um okay i'll give you that japan well
japan was pretty good
and was like mick karn from japan he
made that band with uh peter murphy
later dolly's car
they made they only made one album well
it wasn't even a whole album because it
was only sounds like [ __ ] songs
but i [ __ ] loved that album the
waking hour it was called
and um it's super weird it's really
weird
especially for that time period like
it's very experimental
the funniest thing about [ __ ] the
whole peter murphy
david bowie peter murphy [ __ ]
[ __ ] bauhaus thing is that i remember
[ __ ] seeing him
guest vijay on mtv yeah he was on there
a lot actually
like one of the few times you could
actually like hear anything of peter
murphy's pre-internet
and he came across as this really deep
artistic [ __ ]
soul you know who is [ __ ] real wise
giving you this [ __ ]
gothic wisdom or whatever until you
[ __ ] see the dude in person
person and you know anything about it
it's just hilarious
peter murphy is a douchebag well
the weird thing about peter murphy like
and look i'm not saying because like in
the early 80s
he was different back then super high
oh my god dude he was like the hottest
dude ever like in the 80s
and there's somebody who's involved with
him a certain woman is involved with the
dude
yeah yeah yeah we yeah we know somebody
that knows him
like intimately yeah um so
that's well and his problems don't have
anything to do with that
his pr it's other problems it's not like
i'm saying you know the dude
the weird thing about peter murphy
though is that like i've seen
peter murphy live more easily more than
any other artist like i've seen him solo
i've seen him with bauhaus i've seen him
like all
you know lots and lots of times but he's
he's
like real schizo it's like sometimes you
see him and he's just like
he's cool he's cool and he's like joking
and [ __ ] like that and then sometimes
you see him and he's like
he's like king [ __ ] and he's like i'm
too good for you people and like why
are you people even here and he's just
like he's real like throwing whiskey
bottles into the [ __ ] crowds and
[ __ ] getting thrown out you never
know what you're gonna get
in his own [ __ ] [ __ ] he gets kicked
out of his own show
yeah for like throwing bottle well and
rightly so yeah
[ __ ] bottles he's got uh medical uh
medical
issues he's got medical issues meth is
what we're saying
yeah he got in trouble that was it was
that in here that he he rear-ended that
person and he did a
who was california was it california i
remember randy i wanted to go to
california ran from the scene
[ __ ] was all the time they found a
bunch of meth in his car and then there
was like and then he gave the classic
excuse it's not mine
then he said it's not my math yeah
[ __ ] i'm holding it for
somebody
i don't know no he said he didn't know
where it came from the [ __ ] is a
crackhead
and then he and then of course they say
well in order to just to keep yourself
from getting locked up you're gonna have
to go to rehab because okay yeah i'll do
that
yeah yeah sophie said i agree from old
picks i've seen he was hot as [ __ ] he
was hot as [ __ ]
and like honestly like blonde hair i saw
him
the first time i saw him was in 1990
right after deep came out
nine inch nails opened uh before they
got famous like this was right
like maybe a couple weeks after pretty
hate machine came out
um so everyone it was very funny because
i saw him at the mahaffey theater in st
petersburg in florida and nine inch
nails opened and nobody really knew who
they were at this point i had the album
because i had like
um copied it off a friend of mine
because i was broke
um and i liked it so i knew who they
were and i was just like i was me and my
friend christy were like in the very
very front row
and so we're sitting there and you know
nine inch nails are on and everyone's
just kind of sitting there looking at
him going
huh okay well when's peter murphy gonna
be on come on let's let's
hurry it up so peter murphy comes out
and like i said if you know anything
about peter murphy he'd always had like
black hair like darker hair during the
bauhaus days but
1990 when deep came out which was like
his third solo
yeah um and he had died as he had like
bleached his hair white and it looked
really really good
and we saw him and we were just like
holy [ __ ] and he was like right there
you know what i mean and it was like
right then i was like oh my god he
looked amazing
and then it's just kind of like every
time i saw him subsequently
he was really good when i saw him at 95
which i think was right after cascade
came out
um he looked really good then but it's
like every single time we've seen him
because you and me have seen him a
couple times
together and he just kind of looks worse
and worse like every time we go
and it's really sad because i mean i
think he's through
he used to be i mean he used to be
like beautiful he used to like look so
[ __ ] good and i i
i was hoping that he would go the bowie
route yeah he's not that much older than
me
no he's not he's not that much maybe 10
15 years
then you know what i don't even think
he's that much older [ __ ] looks
like
he looks like [ __ ] yeah um oh maybe 10
years i think maybe he was
maybe he's 59 i want to say he was born
yeah so he's 10 years old yeah so he
looks like he's 30 years older than me
yeah he looks like
yeah bad yeah dawn remember concrete
blood you remember london after midnight
remember london after midnight that was
good i love concrete blonde actually
yeah um yeah they did
i i really liked their cover of uh andy
preboy's
uh tomorrow wendy i don't know that
song's kind of cheesy but i also kind of
love it i love both so she's asking if
he nearly died of a heart attack
recently i don't know
i thought it was something yeah there
was something like that yeah he's not
gonna make it
i'll tell you i tell you one of the goth
dudes though that [ __ ] aged pretty
well
and i from everything i've seen of him
he's a cool guy we've seen him live
that's gary newman we saw gary newman
yeah
how what was it seven years ago about
seven years ago eight years
and he's got his she was awesome i
follow him on instagram he's got his
[ __ ] together too he's showing the
inside of his house and [ __ ] like that
and the [ __ ] that he does
is he's got a real good wife that takes
takes care of him keeps him [ __ ]
well he is he's uh autistic yeah yeah
you know he's got uh or asperger's got
asperger's yeah yeah he's on the
spectrum
yeah and uh he's got a real cute
daughter cute little daughter he made a
little video of her she was probably
about 10 and had her all
dressed up like a post-apocalyptic girl
remember that they're out in the desert
yeah that's right yeah you know he's
family oriented now but
he's [ __ ] doing goth industrial music
he found his [ __ ] sound and he stayed
with it
there were a couple times in the 80s
where he tried to do something else and
it just [ __ ] sucked i mean he tried
to be
bruce springsteen for a while that [ __ ]
[ __ ] suck no one should try to be
bruce springsteen no
he found that [ __ ] slick almost kind
of depeche mode sound and he worked with
a lot of people like
best mode i think he even worked with um
um nitsarev he did a lot of engineering
i think he worked with uh uh trent
rezner with nine inch nails for a while
yeah he he does a lot of studio work
with people and it
he found his sound and he he stuck with
it that's good he's good he's still good
well
everything i mean that's the thing i do
feel like the thing about goth music
and i don't know if this happens in
other genres because i'm not
you know a big follower of other genres
like i like a lot of different stuff but
goth is the one that i you know follow
the most closely i do feel like
goth music is one of the few genres
where nobody wants to admit
that they're that genre yeah you know
what i'm saying i guess it's better now
that it used to be because it doesn't
have
it it you know it doesn't have the
[ __ ] stigma that it used to have
because remember how [ __ ] andrew
[ __ ] eldritch
look i love the sisters of mercy okay
i'm not saying yeah he's a douche though
but
he was the biggest advocate of we're not
a guth man i'm like yes
you are it's like you can't sound like
that
yeah you can't sound like that and then
come out and be a douche and be like
he's just trying to be like contrarian
a standing ovation for [ __ ] uh newman
gary newman in the comment section yeah
he's a class
i mean that was one of the best shows
he's good that was one of the best shows
i've ever brought today
he was so excited and he's really good
live in the first half
of the show he was doing stuff in the
late 70s and the 80s he did all his
classic stuff
and then he went to the into the newer
stuff like dead heaven and
what was this song about he just a lot
of the really good songs you knew from
the 90s
late 90s well [ __ ] man he's still doing
[ __ ] now and they still play it at clubs
i still hear his [ __ ] at
like his new [ __ ] at clubs all the time
sophie says she loves him
and he's still doing good one of the
things about [ __ ] newman i think
that that allows him to kind of
still remain known is that he
understands the power of social media
he's playing the social media game and
if you don't know how to play that game
you're not going to make it well not now
not anymore
and uh so that's good you know [ __ ]
they got that one
rap dude tom what's it tom something or
other
it just pure [ __ ] social media and
his own [ __ ] off of [ __ ] his own
product
and he's a millionaire now and that's
just because he keeps
releasing videos every couple months and
they're
good videos and it's all current events
he doesn't release a album he just
releases a song
yeah one after the other and gets
millions of hits every time he does it
what's he's got you guys drop it in the
comments says tom nick something or
other
i showed it to sophia says there's
something to this guy he
had a really good video about him
talking to his dark side
it's not my kind of music but you know i
i i respect greatness when i see it
tom mcdonald tom mcdonald that's right
tom mcdonough he's very good
everything's about current events and uh
he's making a [ __ ] ton of money
and they're pissed because there's
there's nobody backing him it's just him
and his girlfriend
well like i said if you know what you're
doing exactly um
and you're talented yeah uh you know you
can build your own following yeah
yeah that's how you're gonna do it in
the future and it's kind of like rising
up out of the swamp
it's like natural selection now you know
what i mean
so you get good talent because it's not
a fake talent with a bunch of
money behind it pushing it to the
forefront it's something that rose on
its own
and that social media is the key and uh
i just you know [ __ ] that's something
that newman
realized and he's doing it that way too
kind of
and um he's playing the instagram game
where he's you know
posting inside the hotels and houses and
just whatever and talking to people
and that's how he's keeping his fan base
rejuvenated
you know he can't depend on the people
from the late 70s and 80s now they're
all old
yeah they're not buying [ __ ] like that's
yeah you know where we would be very few
and i'd spend money to go see him
yeah but uh you know because we have but
uh yeah [ __ ] so if if he's playing
down here next time you visit man we'll
we'll maybe we'll hook some up well you
can see him with us yeah we saw him at
that place firestone
firestone that's what it is it's not
firestone anymore we're right up front
it's kind of a smaller venue it's nice
yeah it was really really good i mean
one of the best shows i've ever seen
most of the [ __ ] though that we see is
that um
house of blues disney yeah downtown
disney yeah i feel like a lot of shows
are there
um back in the day we used to have a
place called the edge
that's i saw peter murphy there i saw
christian death there i saw they might
be giants there
social distortion i saw all different
kind of nightish nails a bunch of times
but um
you know that's not there anymore i
think it's a country bar now
unfortunately no it was a country bar
and i think now it's a restaurant
um yeah somebody's like
danny rowling asked a question but then
he redacted it so i was i was gonna
answer it but i don't
i don't remember what he said yes i know
that newman is still putting out albums
yeah and that he is releasing videos
kind of like one after the other and
he's and he's playing the social media
game that's what i'm saying mango said i
remember seeing the sisters and eldritch
came out wearing a hawaiian shirt
yeah that sounds like some [ __ ] that he
would do yeah
tour in [ __ ] mexico and central and
south america though now in these little
tiny venues and he's trying to be as
sisters as mercy as he possibly can well
because like i said you gotta own that
[ __ ]
you can't be a [ __ ] goth and have
your 99
of your fan base what's he gonna do go
back to leads he's gonna go back to
leeds
that's it's like don't
[ __ ] on like 99 of your fan base people
like your [ __ ] because it's gothy
his bald ass up there on a stage filled
with [ __ ] smoke smoked machine you
can barely see you can barely fight i've
seen him
maybe five or six times and it's like
every single time he comes out he's got
he's got all his hair shaved off
he still looks good though three or four
dudes one third one third his age up
there but it's like dry
ice it's like this just impenetrable
don't look at me
it's still a good show but it's just
like it's very funny i think it's become
like a joke at this point where it's
just kind of like you can't even see the
[ __ ]
look i had all of his i had
[ __ ] all the sisters of mercy island
before the [ __ ] band left and became
mission uk that was pretty good i like
i really the best one of the best albums
of all times
is first and last time i never get sick
of that album i really don't yeah that
is one of the best albums of all times
and that's the only reason why you know
who andrew eldridge and the sisters of
mercy are as that album
flood land was okay vision well i think
flood land was the way bigger club hit
because lucretia my reflection and this
corrosion
kind of seeped into mainstream clubs
mother russia
and all that kind of yeah well well
which was kind of like yeah it's all
kind of attached to the yeah it was all
kind of
you know together without song but those
flood one and two
yeah those songs kind of like leech
their way in the mainstream club so it's
like now you go to eye bar
and you're that [ __ ] well yeah i i can't
just kind of feel like if they're gonna
play the sisters of mercy which i don't
have a problem with um
just please play something other i like
those two songs but please play
something other than those two songs
you know what i mean i i feel like
that's the only thing
i love 80s music and i never get sick of
it
but sometimes i feel like um
you know clubs lean too hard on
songs that they know that everybody
knows you know what i mean it's just
kind of like hey if we play new order
we're gonna play blue monday and don't
get me wrong i love blue monday and i
never get sick of that song ever
but why don't you play like 1963 or why
don't you play like
you know a song that's not as ubiquitous
i guess i don't know and the same with
sisters of mercy i'm always just kind of
like if they're going to play sisters of
mercy
well it's just kind of like remember
when i say this to you every time if
you're going to play
because like a lot of times he'll play
like echo in the bunny then yeah what
does he play every time
lips like sugar plays a [ __ ] same old
[ __ ] [ __ ] i was like
look play the cutter play the back of
love play
you know play something play [ __ ] the
killing moon
anything serpent's back they're saying
if i can't see dr avalanche i'm out
for those who don't know dr avalanche
was the drummer for stitches of mercy
and it was a drum machine he's a drum
machine yeah
it was a good thing good thinking though
what the [ __ ] do you need a drummer for
in a goth rock band
you don't you don't okay one less dude
to pay that's one more dude you had to
pay and then
unload all that [ __ ] but um
just there's something i listened to the
first and last and always a couple days
ago
middle of the day i just put that [ __ ]
on on youtube with the big screen
[ __ ] with that album cover [ __ ]
face me i'm sitting there and i wish i
was smoking but i stopped smoking
i'm sitting here you can smoke if you
want yelling
[ __ ] i could vape again maybe but i
haven't faked them forever
no reason to bait i haven't baked them
forever either i can't vape anymore
every time i try to vape now i just
start coughing
i gotta fire that vape back up i got
good vapes in here anyway
listen that album going yeah i was right
i was right all along that this is the
[ __ ] best album of all times
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] just awesome the
lyrics on that album
i kind of feel like if anybody ever asks
me what is the quintessential gothic
rock album the first and last one always
it's first and last and always
because like that [ __ ] on the show and
some random guy that i never heard of
came back and thanked me in the comment
section because dude i wouldn't listen
that is the best album of all [ __ ]
times it is
i mean you know and like i said sister
to mercy not you know it's not my
favorite band but uh you know i'm
they're probably in my top ten top point
just because that album but that album
yeah
the thing well okay so the thing about
it is that if you can love a band and
that's a different thing
than saying this is the best album ever
because an album is a whole
work of art and for an entire album to
the best album ever made
every single [ __ ] song on it has to
be good
yeah and every single song on that is
good
serpent's going yeah play some
amphetamine logic and blood money yeah
why
yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] counter that what
about nine wild nine
nine wine line is actually my favorite
thing about that album that's it yeah
it's it's actually my favorite thing
about it i mean it kind of goes back and
forth but
i just walk away man that's kind of a
yeah just
not well the thing about 9-1-9 i guess
it's because
that's not on that album though no it's
not on that album yeah exactly alice
what about what about what's the other
one the other one um
yeah it's good that's another that's
another good one that's a cover of uh
a hot chocolate song i love that song
yeah it's really good
i love you know what's weird i love
songs about people
killing themselves i don't know why so
it's like
so it's like that song emma every time
you get to that part where he comes in
and she finds her on the floor with the
note
and everything she's [ __ ] dead i know
they didn't write that song but
i like their cover of gimme shelter too
is is also really good they play that at
a bar sometimes
and i'm always very they they always
play it really early because they're
kind of like hey all the ghosts are
going to dance to this and then later on
we can play
erasure and all the normal people dance
to it
you know i'd say you know i'm not
[ __ ] on erasure i like erasure
but i do kind of get to a point where
you go to eye bar like i said it's 80s
night on saturday nights which is my
which is honestly my favorite
thing um you know and they'll play some
kind of gothy [ __ ] earlier
and every now and then they'll throw on
like kind of a curveball like they'll
throw on some mark almond or something
or some cramps um and i'm always like
super excited
but mostly they kind of stick to you
know like erasure
pet shop boys stuff like that which is
fine um
but i'm always kind of like
[Music]
and honestly even if they're gonna do
that i wish they would kind of go more
like
you know do more deep cuts rather than
just like playing the same [ __ ] all the
time
because i feel we used to have a joke oh
thanks we used to have a joke that
whenever they played the smiths they
would always play
um they would always play what
difference does it make
and then immediately afterward they
would always play panic
they always played those two songs
together and i'm not really sure why
so it just became a joke like you go out
there and you because i love the smiths
um i know morrissey's a douche i'm not
gonna say
you know anything about that but um so
they play what difference does it make
i'd go out there and dance and then we'd
just be like
wait for it and there it is there's
panic because they would always play
that afterward i don't know why
um nor like the dude that owns the bar
and he's like i said
[ __ ] fair play to this dude he has he
has owned an independent bar and it's a
giant place
it's been there for more than 30 years
and it has always been successful um
so he likes to he has other djs but he
likes to dj on saturday night because
he's really into 80s music so he always
kind of wants to do it i think he's
lately he kind of farmed it out to
somebody else but um for a long time he
would always so we would always kind of
like tease him about
playing the same two smith songs like he
would always play them one after the
other
i don't know um and he always oh my god
he always plays this one song
i don't hate a lot of 80s songs but
there's this one song who the [ __ ] oh
man i can't remember
it's that [ __ ] uh tom will remember
he likes it but it's that [ __ ] french
song it's in french
damn what the [ __ ] the name of it i
can't remember what the name of it is
but he plays it like pretty much every
single time
and i'm just kind of every time it comes
on i'm like god
[ __ ] damn it and then i go over there
and stand by the wall and tom's like
what i like this song
and then he always like [ __ ] you know
that's that's how we used to spend every
single saturday night
like that [ __ ] french thought coming
on and i'd be like god [ __ ] david
here's this [ __ ] song again he plays
this every week i hate it
but uh you know
yeah see that's why you have to say the
whole album yeah because the hits never
end
that's what i mean first and last and
always like i said you can't ever say
the reason i say that's like the perfect
the quintessential goth album is because
every single song on it
is brilliant every single song on it
is an exemplification of what gothic
rock sounds like
you can't really say that about like
oh okay about like some of my other
albums you know some of my other
favorite albums in the genre like
mask uh the bauhaus album from 82
because that as much as i love that
album that shit's all over the map
there's some [ __ ] glam rock in there
there's some [ __ ] reggae in there
there's some funky punk rock in there
there's all kind of like it's really
like diverse
like every single song sounds completely
wildly different
but that's what i love about it but see
first and last and always is very
cohesive yes it has a mission statement
serpent says that's why you have to say
the whole album because
it's never it's never ending man never
ending hits [ __ ]
planet possession yeah [ __ ] right
amphetamine logic
[ __ ] marianne oh man just every song
walk away
god i love marianne um [ __ ] what else is
on that thing just every [ __ ] song on
that album
first and last and always is the [ __ ]
perfect album
yeah it's not a perfect band but it's
that that's that perfect [ __ ] out
well that was like lightning in a bottle
yeah every [ __ ] song is great
and and really the reputation of that
band is on
that album yeah and you can also say
that the reputation
of [ __ ] mission uk is on that album
because that band
left if you don't know that band left
andrew eldridge and became admission
because wayne hussey they used to be
yeah he used to be in there and there's
good mission uk
albums too that i have i would have
they're a little too
you tooey for me exactly you know that's
the [ __ ] funny thing
is that it sounds kind of like sounds
kind of like sisters of mercy if
bono was [ __ ] singing yeah it does
come out yeah that's what i thought
like i like some of their songs i like
raising kane i like
um you know i like a couple of their
songs but
i never really got into the music i got
that god's own medicine album and it
took me a while to get
used to it but eventually i was like no
this is good this is really good
but like you said it has that bono
[ __ ] sound
yeah it's very you too it kind of sounds
like joshua tree
the lyrics from joshua tree not the best
it was a little too
normal it did it sounded normal but it
it did sound a little normie
for the time it's not bad at all you're
like oh okay i see what they're doing i
like it more now than i did at this year
because at the time it just wasn't it
was too normal sounding like i said it
and i'm not [ __ ] on you two i really
liked i liked the first
two youtube albums i liked a lot of
their stuff i liked it up to october
baby
but that was but that was normie music
yeah that's what i mean that was like
you know yeah i liked boy
yeah i liked you know i liked yeah yeah
i liked war
i liked those two after that they
started to get a little i liked them
when they were kind of like rough and
new wavy and like they were kind of like
the police
yeah like i liked that like they get too
slick or too mainstreamy sounding i'm
like yeah
that's another one for you young [ __ ]
out there you might want to check out
the police
[ __ ] it's a classic synchronicity was
the first album i bought with my own
money ghost in the machine
i was 11 a good one [ __ ] it
it does have a lot of reggae influence
but that's not right though some people
might
understand that because a lot of punker
punk rockers from the uk
listened to reggae well yeah there was
there was a lot of crossover they all
hung out together
but uh back when sting and [ __ ]
summers were [ __ ] rolling they were
really rolling
they were good really goddamn it i love
earlier yeah now was it goth
no but it was really no but it was [ __ ]
friendly jason
like i said i liked a lot of stuff that
maybe wouldn't get
you know maybe at the time wouldn't have
been categorized as goth obviously
but a lot of stuff that would have been
categorized as new wave or post punk if
you want to be even broader about it
i'm so well i like i like using the term
post punk because it's broader that
because that kind of encompasses new
wave
and goth and the weird [ __ ] that came
out after
uh you know after punk happened because
i feel like i don't know if we'll ever
see that again
um well at least
um nothing will get traction yeah i mean
at least to that extent because i feel
like everything everything's like so
broken up broken up nowadays but back
then after punk happened because
really and particularly in the uk i
think punk was over by like 1976 right
in 1977 and so it took longer
for it to you know kind of run its
course in the u.s
but after that happened it was just kind
of like the floodgates were open
like everybody that was into punk
pretty much formed a band and they
didn't make punk bands they just made
weird [ __ ] yeah they just made whatever
they wanted to make and it was awesome
everything is broken up now um but there
are still great bands out there and one
of them is
here in florida a friend of ours in the
industry
named imani jenny does a lot of album
covers for
she does uh black metal usually yeah
black metal usually we were and some
hip-hop we were out to dinner we were
eating indian food
and she's she's from new york and she's
like tommy
you know tommy what's your favorite
trying to do her voice what's your
favorite album what's your what's your
favorite band in florida
you know what do you think the best
being she doesn't sound exactly like i'm
trying to do new york you know
oh i think the best band in florida is a
starry night
[ __ ] signed them it's got his [ __ ]
signed and got them signed
and they are the if you ask me they are
nouveau goth they're kind of like a new
version of the cure
mixed with um what else would you say
kind of like the cure
mixed with early sisters
mission yeah kind of you know what's
hilarious do you remember
when michael first said he's the singer
when he sent
us um before before anything went public
yeah he sent us some demos like from
their new from their new
album and it was the one that was um
that was real like uh that was like
super gothy right yeah
and i was listening to it and i was like
dude i was like that sounds like
uh a lot like christian death yeah yeah
yeah and they were like
who's that yeah
because what had happened was he was
asking me who do i sound like who do i
sound like and i'm listening to it and i
says you can actually remind me of a guy
we used to have called roz williams yeah
he sounds like roswell sound like roz
williams
and and i sent him some music for that
yeah and i think
that muse this that song that they sent
you was based on
the music i kind of feel like it too i
was just like well
yeah that's why i was kind of like i
didn't know who i was kind of like i
kind of find it hard to believe that you
maybe didn't know who christian death
was
yeah because you guys are not it doesn't
sound like they were ripping off
funny man these are young guys but it
was very christian yeah
i mean young guys and they don't know i
mean michael from australia night
is young enough to be my child yeah
that's how young he is and then that
[ __ ] pretends like he don't know me at
the show
ain't that some [ __ ] he's michael white
buying this says what mike what the [ __ ]
and then he walks by like at the show
and then [ __ ] the band members coming
and just they said [ __ ] pretending like
he didn't know me and they [ __ ]
busted there
they said come on come on come on [ __ ]
and then i [ __ ] i'm sitting there
razzing the [ __ ] out of him because he
plays [ __ ] punk games with me like
who's gonna [ __ ] who and all that
it's he plays these he's straight all
right he's very straight well he's
making [ __ ]
you just gave it away anybody to know
that he's married
she's proud of that predatory
[ __ ] but
uh no we i we have fun with those guys
the uh
the guitarist though he's he's our age
pretty much he might be a couple years
younger he knows everything that we know
who howard howard howard knows i could
talk to howard about talking
about movies he knows
everything i would put a starry night
some of their stuff especially the later
stuff almost kind of reminds me of uh
[ __ ] it sounds like an old band
they do yeah it does yeah if you guys
haven't heard it check out a starry
night
a-s-t-a-r-i-n-i-t-t
they're from miami yeah they're from
miami they come up here
they just they do funny [ __ ] they come
up here they used to come up twice a
year yeah jenny does all their album
covers
yeah i don't i didn't do the last one
but i did i did the last couple
okay um and i do like pretty much and if
you ever see a poster or a flyer for any
of their shows i usually would they got
a new company
oh i don't know why didn't you do their
last one i don't even remember why
i think somebody that like a friend of
theirs like knew how to do it yeah
like painted it oh okay all right you
know what i mean yeah because they had
that one girl who actually drew that one
i had the
yeah yeah yeah that's right it was great
that's right yeah but um and they want
didn't want to play live again
but you know this [ __ ] whole covent
thing they were like man we don't want
to look bad because we know you
guys we know that some of these people
are [ __ ] talking [ __ ] about anybody
who's playing live now but we got to get
out and play
remember that they were going to do that
thing at will's pub and they're [ __ ]
great to see at will's pub
that's a good venue that's been there
forever so we got to get you down here
when a starry night plays
will's pub we gotta [ __ ] work
something out for a show you would love
[ __ ] that bad that bad's really good
live
they would like you well and they're
super fun to hang out yeah real funny
i mean like i said i could talk to all
because you know they're all like really
cool
dudes too they're not [ __ ] or
anything ever see
break down kurt russell yes got it on
blu-ray it's great did we do it we did a
review of that did we not
yeah because someone sent us uh the
blu-ray yeah and uh
yeah we did a review on that a little
like a while back somebody brings up bow
wow wow yeah i haven't heard of them in
a long time oh my god yeah
[ __ ] that was one of malcolm
mclaren's bands yeah and i feel like the
the chick that was uh the singer she was
what 14 at the time yeah the
new album is pretty cool gotta listen to
that again yeah
i heard i heard uh i heard most of that
album before the album was out it was
good i gotta go back and get i met those
[ __ ] owe me a copy
i know i haven't talked to him for a
couple of weeks actually
because like i said not a lot of stuff
yes i'd love to see them live with you
guys sounds good
yeah it's in the next few months
something's gonna shake
well they've been wanting to come up
here because they keep asking me like
you know when they can come up here
because i think they were supposed to
come up in december and then that kind
of fell through
we usually go to the hotel with them
afterwards [ __ ] they
they have a bunch of little entourage
that goes to the hotel with them
all these [ __ ] cute girls and [ __ ]
they go to the hotel with them and
[ __ ] hang out
[ __ ] and [ __ ] they're always
trying to like talk us into doing
[ __ ] that we'll probably regret yeah you
know he wants to stay all night
[Laughter]
i gotta pull that [ __ ] i gotta pull that
[ __ ] like the [ __ ]
with the [ __ ] they're like half our
age yeah
but not really i mean you know it
doesn't seem to be
you know what i mean but i never get
this i'm pulling that freddy mercury
[ __ ] with me
when he gets in bed and wants me to hold
his hand
and he wants me to call him bubbler
it's gonna be all right it's gonna be a
great show do you remember
last time we saw them and we went up to
their hotel room and we were like kind
of they're just like hanging out and
drinking
yeah and i remember laughing like i was
pretty drunk because we've been at the
show earlier too
and like i remember laughing my ass off
because michael
had an attachment for his cell phone
that was just like an
old-fashioned yeah yeah you know what i
mean
you remember like old school like back
in the 70s like the [ __ ] phone
receiver that you put on there
he had one of those and it was like
actual size and it hooked up to his cell
phone so he could talk to his cell phone
and then he gave us a girl and i was
like baby [ __ ] laughs so far
he gave us that girl remember oh my god
here take her take her take this one she
slept at our house
did she not yes take her we didn't know
what to do with her
what take her get her out of here take
her well he didn't want her
he didn't want her she was a huge
i mean she was kind of [ __ ] up on some
[ __ ] but we were all kind of [ __ ] up
she was trying to get some and there was
and they were just kind of like yeah
there was
oh there was like a pecking order or
something yeah and they're kind of like
well
yeah no we can't have that tom jenny
take her
take her with you so what we had yeah we
had to take her with us
and then so we brought her back to our
house
and we put it we have a guest room so we
put her in the guest room and then the
next day oh you remember that
the next day yeah she wanted us to drop
her off at the cemetery
yeah because she was doing what was she
doing she was
yoga in the cemetery yoga in the
cemetery yeah so then i it was super
weird it was just like the weirdest
yeah and she was in a weirdest night he
was in this black baby doll outfit with
[ __ ]
like die high black and white striped
stockings and [ __ ]
knee-high gog boots the big [ __ ]
platforms and she had the [ __ ] big
old [ __ ] ponytails
and the remember she had yeah one of the
boobs she did for school
she was cool yeah she's good she's a
boost i like that and we just [ __ ]
dropped her off in the middle of a bunch
of [ __ ] cemetery
she starts doing her [ __ ] yoga
because there was nobody there and i was
just kind of like are you sure that this
is where you want us to drop you off
[ __ ] yeah there's nobody here yeah she's
like nah man it's fine
i'm just like yeah so we steer all the
time we see the same girl all the time
though
she with a girl we're calling her a girl
she was about 40.
yeah well he's about four everybody's a
girl to me yeah she's about 40.
dj maniac she's like a girl yeah dj
maniac says i think we're both friends
with ludovico technique
yeah i did a show with him ages ago yeah
although i haven't seen lv for years
ben and um who's his friend air force
guy
uh guy who actually writes all the music
evan evan yeah yeah oh my god i can't
wait long time i can't believe i pulled
that up
you also know heaven's ex oh then they
were fighting out in the middle of the
damn [ __ ] street
remember that [ __ ] yeah oh she went
flying can we like not
i'm not going to say what her name is
i'm not saying i said where the name was
name is susan oh well dude was cute girl
who was [ __ ] crazy as [ __ ] and been
just in love with that dude and he was
trying to break up with her all the time
and she'd be chasing him [ __ ] it
and [ __ ] running it running after his
ass as he's trying to get away and she
[ __ ] trips and goes [ __ ] flying
hits the ground she busted her face
outside in the middle of orange avenue
downtown orlando and he turned around
says you're all right she jumped up
boom and punched him right in the
[ __ ] face and [ __ ] that was something
yeah and then it's just out in the damn
street we were all like out on the patio
like in front of eyebar
going like we're all just like hilarious
man oh
yeah it's like what did that just
[ __ ] yeah
but um ludovico technique um i have
that one album that they gave me the
ones that yeah
it's old now but it was good it was good
the problem with it is that the market
just just you can't do anything with
that kind of music
well we used to saturated i mean we used
to talk to evan a lot like
he would come out because ben b is kind
of a diva a little bit
but evan's cool and every time he would
come out we would kind of talk to him
about it and he's just kind of like man
you can't like make any money
yeah making music anymore which you know
obviously like
you probably can't because they're just
gonna like steal your [ __ ] for free
i get it yeah they're a good band though
we've seen them live
a couple of times yeah they're good live
two or three times
ben puts on a [ __ ] great show they do
yeah it looks psychotic
just [ __ ] crazy
ben is crazy though a little bit yeah he
is crazy
it's we i don't know it's weird i
haven't seen him i think the last time
i'm one of the few [ __ ] that
can get along with ben
a lot of people can't get along with ben
he's challenging yeah but
uh he's challenging yeah but you just
gotta be real honest with ben ben
doesn't like any [ __ ] [ __ ]
and if you give him any [ __ ] then he
comes back on you so he likes
do you have to be super honest you have
to be very reasonable
he doesn't like [ __ ] normal scene
people he has the militant outlook on
things
that's that's why he has that's why a
lot of people have which i get it i get
it
um anybody that is that
um rigid i don't know i don't know if
that's the word i want to use he's
disciplined
he's disappointed and he did he kind of
does come kind of i kind of like him
there there's i like him
he comes from i think he comes from a
background of hardship
i think that's what it is so he does not
like any beating around the bush he
doesn't like any kind of [ __ ]
he doesn't like any [ __ ] fakeness you
know
you have to be who you are which i get
that i get that right i'm a little bit
like that too yeah
um well think okay but i'm not going to
like get all up in your face about it
i'm just going to be honest
he's not either you have to understand
who what
who he's dealing with in the scene a lot
of people [ __ ] him
yeah and then when he calls [ __ ] on
it then all of a sudden they're mad at
him that he called [ __ ] on it
that's what happened remember what he's
mean
he's mean because he tried to get you
tried to put one over on it
well i kind of feel like that's a
universal problem because
people people are always kind of like
look it's like everybody has you know
you know i'm the star of my own movie
blah blah everybody has that going on
so it's kind of like you don't really
realize if you're being a dick to other
people
and like people are treating you like
you're a dick and but you don't think
you are
so you feel like it's that person's
fault so sometimes
like people put up with that kind of
crap for a long time and then finally
they're like look man i'm just like not
even gonna i'm just gonna
yeah i'm gonna peace out and i'm just
gonna like tell you so and then like
suddenly you're the [ __ ] what's great
i get it i get it what's great
is that our connection is [ __ ] doing
great
how long we've been streaming two hours
and 27 minutes okay
well honestly i mean the show we did
last saturday about texas killing fields
we went almost four hours
without it dropping i think it just
depends on
the time it just depends on i don't know
man
it's just it's weird because sometimes
we we would just do a [ __ ]
matinee in the middle of the day like a
three in the afternoon that would just
drop after 20 minutes
somebody gave this stream a thumbs down
one person did get the [ __ ] off the
[ __ ] string
i guess because when we're there we're
talking about something they don't know
what we're talking about
oh no people on top listen and learn
[ __ ] there's a whole other culture
there's a whole other thing
there's a whole other universe that you
don't know anything about yeah well you
know that
well that's the thing and like i said
that kind of goes back to
i don't i don't know man i don't really
get this whole
why would you like watch part of a video
and then just like put a thumbs up i
never i don't think i have ever in my
entire life
what we're talking about put a thumbs
down on a video we're gonna talk about
the gothic culture
and uh maybe we've got two sidetracked
on that [ __ ] no we were talking about it
we were telling you that that was the
whole idea of part of this stream anyway
and we got a lot of goths in the damn
comment section talking about it
probably [ __ ] goth checking our asses
to make sure we're legitimate and
[ __ ] right we're legitimate
we [ __ ] wrote this [ __ ] we wrote that
[ __ ] bro we were there for it
yeah we remember all that [ __ ] it's just
the normal show you know what i mean it
has to have kind of a [ __ ] you have
to cast a wider net
you have to have a mainstream kind of
appeal and
uh most of the people right now in the
goth scene are young they don't have any
money or anything to throw your way
you have to appeal to a [ __ ] wider
audience so we
can't talk about this all the time it's
not the main part of the show
but no we came up in the scene and did
all kinds of cool [ __ ] and [ __ ]
coveted and all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's been happening the past couple
years kind of put a damper on it but i'm
[ __ ] sick of it i'm ready to just
i'm going to go out and a lot of other
people that we know our age that are
going out [ __ ] angel and all her
[ __ ] friends and
all the old school [ __ ] god people at
least going to mannequins
yeah we'll probably get a mannequin
we're going to go let's go to mannequins
i'll warm up at mannequins
and then we're going to then we'll go
back down and we're going to go back and
we're going to start because man i want
to go back to 80s tonight i'm going to
jump start
i don't even give a [ __ ] if they play
eraser i'm dancing that [ __ ] i'm going
to jump start eye bar
[Laughter]
all i gotta do is get on facebook and go
people
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] eye bar if you're not
there i'ma [ __ ] you up
something like that i don't give a [ __ ]
if they come on about all this coke
i don't give a [ __ ] you're gonna die
anyway um you're gonna die if you don't
go and make sure of it
you better go to the [ __ ] club [ __ ]
it's gonna be like that sounds
threatening i'm good yeah i'm
threatening
i'm gonna it's gonna be like natural
resuscitation
looks like an artificial reset is
resuscitation but we resuscitate this
[ __ ]
like you know it's it's weird i'm
conflicted because it's like yeah i
don't want to give everybody my cooties
but
in another way like you know you gonna
catch it anyway well no
well no what i was gonna say was that
you know we used to go to eye bar
all the time um you know five times a
month
and our friends work there and
they're really not making any money you
know what i mean and yeah we were
talking to tiff last time we were
memento mori
and she was just kind of like every time
somebody talks i mean
she's got kids and a husband and it's
like you know she's got to work
every time people on facebook talk about
going to the club somebody else jumps on
them and say don't you dare go
don't you dare go be responsible you're
just [ __ ] these people got to eat man
there's got to be an economy like i said
there's kind of like i don't mind
wearing a mask i totally don't but it's
just kind of like um
you know i don't know it's kind of like
about you're gonna die
anyway these other people are gonna die
anyway
i realized that at [ __ ] 20 when i
[ __ ] signed up for my first first
war i'm gonna die anyway it doesn't
matter
and the more you cling to life the more
miserable you will die when your time
comes
just go out and don't worry about it let
nature take its [ __ ] course
i try not to worry about that don't
worry about it i mean you can't just
like not worry about anything or
anything i don't worry about anything i
[ __ ] hang outside of a helicopter
with a [ __ ] m16 [ __ ]
shooting well no i'm i'm just yeah i'm
just saying that but you can't like
not worry about [ __ ] like in the sense
that you're just like [ __ ] over other
people that's not cool i don't like
other things
they would burn me at the stake probably
anyway no they wouldn't you don't
you don't know them those people are bad
nobody would they were they're probably
he thinks
everybody's bad they're probably bad he
probably thinks
he probably thinks i'll be flying down
the [ __ ] road at 145 miles an hour
and um these [ __ ] are bad i'm
not worried about it
i'm not worried about it i came here to
have fun all right
life is a [ __ ] limited thing and you
only get you're only given a certain
amount of years you know what i mean
it's gonna end with you dying that's how
it is it's going to happen
sooner or later one way or the other so
you might as well so
what that means is that you don't really
have anything to lose
you don't you just don't
tammy says just don't lick anyone else's
drink glass i'm gonna lick all them
[ __ ]
don't do i'm gonna pull my [ __ ] out of
my pants and just rub it along
just grab a drink and just rub it around
the rim like a [ __ ]
leaving salt behind it no one wants your
no one wants your dick
i'm just going to maximize it i'm going
to [ __ ]
i'm going to [ __ ] contaminate the
entire
ecosphere with your tom cote i don't
give a [ __ ] anymore
dj maniac says i describe this show to
my friends as two elder goths from
florida talking about true crime and
cults
[Laughter]
dana ready says have you mentioned
dracula yet we actually haven't we're
getting around to it
we watched that dracula last night the
fact that he's talking about yeah the
1979
okay we can talk about it yeah 99
dracula
uh watched it had very [ __ ] low
expectations for the movie saw it was
impressed i told you it was good
it was good it um kinda up there with dr
with bram strokers dracula the one that
had [ __ ] different gary oldman
francis coppola liked that but played a
little straighter
but quality of the [ __ ] film was
really good
quality the writing the story they
switched some [ __ ] around but it didn't
make me mad
it was very much kind of like a hammer
film like an upgraded hammer horror film
it's like more romance than a horror
film but they kind of acknowledge that
that's kind of what they were going for
i will say though and this is kind of
going back to because i know somebody
asked about scariest things she is darn
she says she got clocking at work she
said love
you too we love you too it'll be okay
yeah
yeah i know work sucks but um
yeah so we were talking about scariest
scenes somebody asked me about it and i
talked about a few like on the last side
tracks
one of the scariest scenes when i was
little because this movie came out in
1979
um the one with frank langella the the
one that john badham directed
and the scene where uh
van helsing played by uh
lawrence olivier of all people uh
is down in the mines and mina
which i'll get into a minute because
they messed up all the characters but
okay
and she kind of like appears in the
puddle and then he looks up and he sees
her
and she's all [ __ ] up looking when i
was a kid
that scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me i
used to have
and i just remembered this yesterday you
guys like straighten it out straighten
it out no it's john battam's [ __ ]
dragon yeah that's what i just said okay
because some people were asking yeah
that was interesting
um when i was a kid i loved this movie
and uh i was seven when this came out i
think i was probably eight
or nine when i saw it and
i had the novelization of it
which was kind of like the book dracula
but more
geared toward the movie and it had um
color pictures in the center and one of
the pictures
was of mina with all the [ __ ] makeup
like going like like that that
and i had to flip past it like when i
was little because it scared me so bad
i don't know why it's just there was
something about the way she looked that
like really freaked me out
but yeah something we were talking about
last night and i meant to look this up
today and i've totally forgot about it
so this movie frankly angela played
dracula right and he plays him like as a
more
romantic figure which fine now frankly
angela had actually been playing dracula
on stage
for more than a year i think prior to
the filming of this movie which is why
they wanted him to be in this movie
because he they'd seen the stage play
he had some lugosi action going he was i
forgot how good he was in this i've
like i saw this movie like a lot when i
was a kid and but i hadn't seen it for a
really long time
and somebody sent me the blu-ray yeah if
you guys have seen the francis ford
coppola
dracula visually it's not quite as
stunning it's it's different it's got a
different tone
but i will give it this the acting is a
lot better
you don't it is yeah you don't have to
worry about [ __ ] canoe reeves [ __ ]
accents yeah [ __ ] what's her name
sorry kiana we do love you yeah yeah
you're great [ __ ] in case you're
watching that's right [ __ ] you can
shoot too i've seen you at the range i
love keanu i do
yeah he's good just don't be imperious
he's [ __ ] john wick he's [ __ ]
great too that's his role it's just that
they got him in that movie for box
office draw i understand it
but he just that accent i just wish it
had all been brits and when nona when
known as accent wasn't all that
no yeah she was well she was a lesser
offense so i kind of feel like
since keanu was in it yeah you know the
focus was kind of taken off her
right because she wasn't quite as bad
yeah
and i love winning a writer too but yeah
also not her thing
yeah now keanu did not ruin that movie i
still love that movie
i do too i love that movie yeah he
didn't ruin it no um
and and i've we've watched it recently
it's a good movie
um it's just that in terms of just
acting and
sheer authenticity in terms of
no he didn't really have an authentic
sound but i understand why he was in it
and [ __ ] it's a great movie
but i tell you what man gary oldman
knocked it out of the [ __ ] park in
that movie i mean
gary oldman is just rad and everything
he's good
he's good the first time i saw him was
in sid and nancy
i saw him at [ __ ] i saw him at the
convent down the french quarter
yeah you told me yeah so yeah i didn't
recognize him at first
i didn't really talk to him much there
he was with a woman there's a problem
well yeah don't look yeah
don't don't [ __ ] like you just [ __ ]
look and say hey what's up man
it was kind of a problem yeah
it wasn't that much of a thing back then
you know i mean he hadn't been around
that long in my mind
you know i mean but [ __ ] yeah i kind
of feel like he didn't really get super
famous
well i don't know was he super crazy to
me
with [ __ ] jerry springer springer and
that [ __ ] sand club me and jerry
springer were [ __ ] sitting there
watching the damn private bondage show
with the couple [ __ ] it was like four
feet from us he's [ __ ] putting her
through
all kinds of bondages he [ __ ]
springer's like this [ __ ] this place is
[ __ ] great man this place is
like yeah yeah he's buying around his
shirt i just met jerry springer i was
got
out as a [ __ ] and hanging out
with jerry springer in the fridge what
was he wearing did i ever
[ __ ] [ __ ] it was just a t-shirt
and bermuda shorts and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] flip-flops from what
i remember it was like there's no
gary springer it dipped because he had
some [ __ ]
he was dressed he was dressed to be on
[ __ ] bourbon street
you know what i mean and try to kind of
like fit in
and [ __ ] pierre who ran the [ __ ]
club says jerry springer and he goes
yeah yeah
come on in yeah because he's like here
in hilarious
pierre let him in okay don't have fun
good and
he's he dropped a lot of money in the
place okay and it's a
if you guys don't know so it's gone now
so i can say
it was a it was actually like a fake
club that had a dj
booth a [ __ ] dance floor a bar a
staff and everything but didn't have a
liquor license
and it was above a
a [ __ ] antique shop owned by a goth
dude and he would
bring people in and he lived in that
club and he would bring well it's like a
private
yeah there's a private you can get away
with a lot because you're calling it
like a private party
yeah but he was selling alcohol but
around the way you know you had to it's
a gray area
you had to [ __ ] turn you had to
donate
that's what i mean that's how you get
away with it it's just saying you know
it's a
it's a five dollar donation yeah that's
how churches get around
yeah and him and his wife you know
controlled the door and the door was so
[ __ ]
just a damn staircase that ended
in a [ __ ] iron gate with a red light
outside of it and i only knew it was
there because i checked on the internet
on an internet with some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] in the [ __ ]
in 98 oh you know what i mean like
internet you find a club on internet
yeah
i found that [ __ ] i knew because it was
a private [ __ ] club oh by god
it was the only goth club in new orleans
at that time
and then across the street across the
street was the [ __ ] crystal and some
of you guys who were from the new
orleans there knew exactly what i'm
talking about
but no that place is [ __ ] badass but
it was only open for like a year or so
he moved away i kind of feel like
because here's what happened with let's
talk about like the castle in tampa
yeah what happened with the castle in
it's in ibor city
actually which is like a little bit it's
kind of like the historic
district like right outside of tampa
what happened with that was that
it used to be the castle used to be like
really cool because
it was kind of there's a if you don't
know eboor city has this
they're kind of like main drag which i
think is 7th avenue
and that's kind of where all the clubs
are and that's like where all the
you know normal people hang out it's
like they go and drink
the castle is two blocks down
and a couple blocks up so it's like at
ninth and sixteenth
so you can't really you don't wander
past it or but you didn't back in the
old days if you were like on the main
drag like where all the clubs are
you didn't like wander past it and be
like oh hey i wonder what this is you
know what i mean
so it was kind of cool because it was
kind of like off on its own
you kind of had to know where it was and
it was kind of like it was on this
little dead end
um it wasn't even a street honestly it
was just kind of like a little
cul-de-sac and it was just kind of at
the end of that
but what happened was that a few years
back probably several years back at this
point
they built um essentially an outdoor
mall right across the street from
the castle um so there's store there's
shops there's restaurants
there's other clubs right there yeah
so now i mean i haven't been there since
the vampire ball a couple years ago
like that we went to but
it was a lot more fun when you just
didn't get rando's wandering in there
because you get randos wandering into
goth clubs
you get trouble all the [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] goths are in there going [ __ ]
crazy
maniac says [ __ ] no name no name club
in brooklyn was like that you told me it
was kind of like the [ __ ]
the combat is what it was called yeah um
rick shaw was jerry springer's goth i
knew it
although shorts no no self-respecting
goth would be seen in bermuda
jerry springer wasn't golf but he got
goth he understood it
but i would say he was really more he
liked [ __ ] fetish
[ __ ] that was going on in here a lot of
it yeah and at the convent at that time
had that new orleans french quarter
old-fashioned look in that club it
looked like something out of [ __ ]
interview with a vampire
that's what it looked like he [ __ ]
loved it he did
um and everybody was cool to him uh
oldman also liked it and then there was
like funny stories from that club
they wouldn't let marilyn manson in and
he threw a [ __ ] fit i love it
i love it we were getting so much [ __ ]
and it was and at that time at that time
um
trent resner all lived in new orleans
yeah and
he brought marilyn manson with him to
the [ __ ] club
and everybody's like no no not wasn't
everybody it was just pierre at the
gates
i love it yeah i love it but i saw
resner in there before
this is back in the 90s they both lived
in town like why you bring that dude
i think pierre eventually let him in
after he showed
marilyn manson who was boss that he you
know what i mean
this is my [ __ ] private house you
know what i mean because it was
technically his don't you come in here
and poop on the floor like you did in
your documentary well what it was is at
that time we were catching so much [ __ ]
because the columbine shooting yeah
and [ __ ] if you were got they were
[ __ ] throwing goddamn [ __ ] bottles
at you
and out of the cars as they were driving
because of marilyn manson and the
columbine shooting if they go
that's it they throw a [ __ ] damn
bottle dude i remember standing in line
to get in the castle and like people
would be behind like
you know yuppy-ish looking people being
behind you going like oh i love marilyn
manson and i think it's like you know
what go [ __ ] yourself
yeah another guy was up on that [ __ ]
balcony looking out [ __ ] rezner
it's not on trent reznor [ __ ] stories
reznor leaves the [ __ ] convent and
gets into his [ __ ]
ferrari he had a [ __ ] ferrari it was
because of course he did
yeah and it was a used ferrari
he gets in his [ __ ] ferrari and turns
that [ __ ] on
he's rolling the windows down and we
like that and guess what comes on
hit like a hole yeah [ __ ]
listening to his own music and everybody
on the down everybody i was with on the
[ __ ]
balcony up there started laughing one
dish
trying to get people to recognize him
can you imagine if you were in a band
listening to your own music in the car
and
not not just that like i feel like if i
was in a band and i was looking at my
own music in the car i would keep the
windows rolled up and i would give it to
i would keep it to myself
i didn't recognize him i'm not gonna
roll down the windows and be like [ __ ]
check it this is me
it's me i didn't recognize him he was in
that he was in the club all [ __ ]
night i had no idea who he was
until [ __ ] i was out there so funny i
was out there and [ __ ] people were
talking
the girl next to me was saying there he
is who's that he goes trent resner he
was walking along and he got into the
damn cars
i said that's true and turned on and hit
like a hole comes out and everybody's
gonna live he was in there all the time
i didn't know that it was trent rezner
because he just dressed like a regular
dude
oh my god that's so funny yeah i know he
was that's just really really
interesting
because that's just something that i
would never that would never
occur to me to do that that would never
occur to me that was back in the day
when celebrity meant something
it doesn't mean anything honestly like
we do these shows
i never watch them again ever no
do them once i do nobody else who may
create some either because we know
what's in them
we know what's in we don't have to watch
them again i just i don't know like i
find i don't know i think
it's got people listening to our back
catalog i find myself i'm catching up i
find myself very
really cringy so i find it like really
embarrassing to like listen to myself
everybody says that though but yeah
that's that's kind of what it says i
sometimes i have to like i said if i
record a book review or something like
that i have to listen to it again to
edit it
but other than that like the live shows
i don't ever
well what's funny is that in my
generation the greatest the greatest
[ __ ] entertainer on radio the radio
is a [ __ ] dead
genre now nowadays that would be youtube
youtube is kind of like radio now yeah
podcast kind of like a radio the
greatest one of my generation was
[ __ ] howard stern howard stern
couldn't listen to himself either
he didn't bother and evidently he sucks
now he didn't age too well his whole
show and like he doesn't have the
support he used to
and it's radio and evidently he wouldn't
even make a good podcaster he wouldn't
even make a good [ __ ] youtuber
i have a hard time believing that but
people have said that
yeah i don't know i can't judge because
i can't i don't know
a long time i think he's on that sirius
xm radio which is like a paid for radio
thing and
yeah evidently that's kind of dying it's
truckers and people in their cars only
i mean have you heard me well that kind
of comes with i mean sometimes when you
buy
cars i think that kind of comes as like
a subscription but i'm telling you guys
i know some of you people
may be old enough to remember the air
and some of you may not be old enough to
even remember it
in the day when howard stern first
appeared back in the 90s it was
mind-blowing it was because it was kind
of pre-internet
and he was getting away with saying
things well no one else was
doing that yeah it was a kind of a big
influence on me even though
his material was very juvenile but it
was just very
it was he was what they call a shock
jock back then yeah and i was like oh
man
there's a lot of those going on yeah but
he was like the main one
yeah you know and uh he would bring
things to light
that mainstream media would not bring to
light to like
you know what i mean like he he was
really good interviewer he'd interview
[ __ ] pam anderson or [ __ ] ask him
[ __ ] personal questions
they never did it on tv and really you
know i get on this show this
that was like one of my biggest
influence of probably howard stern i
[ __ ] liked howard stern
but the old howard stern in that context
that doesn't exist yeah well because
nowadays i mean you can't
shock anyone like everyone is making
their own youtube videos just
you know confessing to all kinds of [ __ ]
so it's
no one is shocked by anything anymore so
it's not the same
what i learned from stern though all
right is that he was the first guy
in mass media that ever just that that
just he just was himself
he you know he'd [ __ ] around but he was
always just himself it wasn't scripted
and really that's what i learned you
know because i i had classical training
too for theater
and i [ __ ] really didn't like that
you know i mean it is a skill into its
own
but it's just so much better just to
just be your [ __ ] self and that's
really a lot of problems with
the old media was that that's not who
that is that's all deception
yeah i mean and honestly i think it's
it's not like we have a big massive
audience with this show but it's like
nobody has a massive audience anymore
well that well that's the thing and
one of the things that i told you and i
think i even remember telling you this
like before we even started the show
it's just like i want it to just be us
being normal i don't people who like it
yeah it's like i don't really want to
like
put on anything i just want us to be
like
we normally would be without the camera
on
you know what i mean and i think we've
largely been successful in doing that
probably like i said
especially since we've been doing the
live streams because and getting drunk
on them
terry's clapping but i don't know what
she's clapping about
that crazy people rolling they must be
talking about when i was talking about
uh
front row with jerry springer and sarah
yeah
that is pretty crazy i mean thurman says
tommy you need to go back and listen to
the necrophiliacs episode
what about it i remember it because you
because you took off at the end
that still makes me laugh yeah well that
was a [ __ ] gross episode
[Laughter]
you've gotten better though yeah i mean
all the gross [ __ ] we've talked about
mango brings up art bell
i've said it many times hold on i gotta
get it back okay
okay said it many times before on the
show already
our belt was another influence of mine
and probably yours too
and back in the day radio kind of had a
certain mystique to it
you had to go out of your way to get a
radio and
find a [ __ ] dial because it wasn't
television or cable television it wasn't
as easy you had to find it
and it was kind of like you were
listening to an underground
[ __ ] something you would find like on
the dark web that
that's that would be the equivalent of
those days we had internet
but it wasn't streaming yet it was
pretty primitive
and i would [ __ ] zoom in on [ __ ]
howard house or
on art bell i might be in mississippi
or louisiana and it was hard to actually
find the station and it was always kind
of a little bit rough and i'd sit there
all night
making little micro adjustments
listening to [ __ ] art bell
and he could take the dumbest [ __ ]
subject and make that [ __ ] sound
[ __ ] like so interesting you know i'm
like oh man
he could make you feel like you were
hearing information that you weren't
supposed to be hearing
he'd be amazed over the [ __ ] looking
back on it it was dumb [ __ ]
but he knew exactly what he was doing
you know and today
we will speak with a man
who has a hole behind his house
that goes to hell that's right ladies
and gentlemen
a hole to hell in the backyard
so we're going to talk about that later
on tonight yeah that's what the [ __ ]
our bell would do and he totally took it
seriously yeah it is and it was just
like he takes some [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
the mueller scout makes it sound all
yeah yeah
i still remember the show that you were
listening to about the dude that said he
took an elevator to mars
yeah elevator to mars and art bell
totally
he was he did not make fun of the dude
no he wasn't condescending
yeah even though the dude was clearly
crazy and today
we will be talking about the muller sky
car the sky the car that all of us will
own
right now straight out of the jetsons
we'll be flying at
200 miles an hour to any location you
can dream of
the mueller sky car next year yeah that
[ __ ] never appeared
mueller was stealing so much [ __ ]
money is the [ __ ]
that thing could [ __ ] fly if it was
shaped like a like a quadcopter
i mean i was remember seeing pictures of
it going man that'd be badass
but it just looks like the future yeah
it looks like the future it would have
been better if it was just a quadcopter
with a [ __ ] capsule sitting on it
you could do that now but you know it
was just
that was a long time ago and the [ __ ]
mueller sky car never appeared
some of them were round like a flying
saucer yeah yeah she was awesome
it was just another it was just another
era if you guys were
not old enough to remember that well the
thing about it too is i think a lot of
people
like you said we're just kind of like
truckers or we're on road trips or
whatever and they're just like
wanted something to listen to for
entertainment
he said he'd listen to most of our
backlog tom and jenny rock oh thank you
very much well thank you
yeah i think we've gotten a lot better
but you know i didn't
import well we're a little more
realistic about what the show is about
and [ __ ]
and it's really not about drinking
sometimes we got too drunk on a damn
show but that's the show
that the show well at this point i just
every now and then like i get anxiety
about it sure
because i have anxiety about everything
but
at you know in the end i'm just like you
know what [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
this is what we're like yeah um even if
we weren't on the show
we don't drink every night like i said
we're not alcoholics i'm you know
but sometimes like we'll put on a movie
like
when we were watching heat the other
night which is dude like three hours
long right
um and i had probably
three very three this size drinks that
night
but i must say i still kept track of the
plot better than you did though
because you're like wait who's this yeah
sometimes they kind of flip the [ __ ]
around wait
wait what's going on and i'm like no
this is that guy with the thing in the
thing and i was just like woo
and i impressed myself they're talking
about george nat and stuff
uh george knapp i think he's better than
the other guy was nori i didn't never
like george oh my god that dude like
irritated
me well he just always sounded like he
sounded like he was
making fun of you like always he didn't
want to do that show he wasn't he wasn't
art
plus he hung up on people remember he
hung up on that dude that had like a
cold or something and that i don't know
why that baby
yeah that just made me so bad that he's
like yeah why don't you just call back
when you're not sick click or something
or something like that but it was just
kind of like i don't know it just made
me early i remember george knapp is
being better but i haven't heard the sh
i haven't heard coast to coast recently
i don't even know if coast to coast
like i said i don't even [ __ ] listen
to radio coast to coast needs to be on
youtube or it needs to be streaming
on twitch or some stupid [ __ ] like that
it's just radio is just
radio is just not a thing unless you're
[ __ ] driving
you know that's it well as i said most
newer cars have
like satellite radio where you would
like listen to podcasts and stuff like
that so
yeah people have to get get up to speed
with what it is
the business models all have to adapt to
modern technology that's just across the
[ __ ] board well and
they will it'll just take a long time
because they're so worried
you know everything is just like you
know changing so rapidly that it's just
taking them a long time to like catch up
with
that's what i like about that's what
covet and all this reset is about you
guys are quick i'm thinking that some of
you people
[ __ ] want to believe that you want to
believe and yeah i don't believe what
they tell me
this is all because of a [ __ ] bunch
of political stuff that they didn't like
and also the fact that
technology has made cities obsolete
you don't you can work from home you
don't need office buildings
business was a commercial real estate in
these downtown areas is the main reason
why that damn city is sitting there
the rest of the city is support for
those office buildings
once those office buildings are obsolete
you don't need a city
that's why the cities are going to fall
apart so they they don't know what the
[ __ ] they're going to do
the scams that made these [ __ ]
filthy rich
are long gone now so they're trying to
engineer a new business model
so they can [ __ ] you over but technology
doesn't allow them to [ __ ] you over
anymore like they used to
so the ruling class is becoming obsolete
because their scams are obviously
obsolete at a technological level
so they're trying to retaliate they're
going to lose
but they're trying to retaliate well
there's more of us broke-ass
there's more of us broke-ass
[ __ ] that are talented with
high technology than there are those
[ __ ]
fellow ghosts and they don't like it
bellagosi says coast to coast kind of
sucks now
it probably does nori sounds drunk to me
he always sounded not so much drunk he
just sounds really yeah he sounds like
snotty and condescending yeah
um which is why i never i don't know
like art bell always sounded like
grandfatherly you know what i mean or
avuncular
you know it he always just kind of
sounded like he wasn't um
talking down to you he always even if
you were saying like really stupid [ __ ]
which a lot of people did that called in
um he wasn't he wasn't condescending in
any way and i don't feel like george
nori has
mastered that and like i said i'm not
judging because
hell if most of the people that called
into art bell called into me and i had
that radio show i would probably sound
pretty kindly sending too
so you know i'm i'm not real good at
like hiding but it's like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about you crazy ass
person
but art bell was like actually really
good at that and i don't think george
nori is but you know like i said
that's kind of how uh that goes rick
says they have a youtube channel but
they only upload little clips which
that's kind of a shame
um you know one thing i wanted to bring
up
because like i said we were talking
about dracula and then like he went off
on a tangent
but i wanted to bring this up because
this is something
if you guys have like i'm i really like
um cinemassacre
right the youtube channel and he did
james did a really good
video where he was trying to find
the most accurate adaptation
like the most accurate film adaptation
of the novel of dracula
now it came with spoiler alert but
the winner was it was a tie between the
francis ford coppola version and the bbc
version um you know just because they
had quincy morris in there they had
a lot of the stuff in there even though
francis ford coppola's version went like
wildly off the rails and added a bunch
of [ __ ] that wasn't in there
um they did actually have a lot of [ __ ]
from the novel that hadn't been in other
uh adaptations now the weird thing about
the 1979 one which i always thought was
really strange and i've seen a couple of
other adaptations that did this and i
don't really know why they
did it i let puke in oh poops back in
yeah what's funny she comes in and she
runs sideways you notice that
like it's not the front legs in front of
the back legs it's like this and she
runs that way
yeah she runs she runs [ __ ] she's the
weirdest kind of funniest cat ever she
[ __ ]
shows off running sideways it makes it
faster i guess
i'm faster i'm gonna get it
she's a whacked out what's she been
doing she's been hanging on the back
porch i guess so she came through she's
looking for that other kitty
yeah that's what it is because i told
you guys
there's another kitty i'm sure i don't
know if it's a stray i think it looks
like i think it belongs to someone else
and it belongs it looks just like her a
little bit bigger
it's got two but has a tail yeah um and
a little bit fluffier
but about the same size yeah a little
bit rounder head
and they i think they're buddies because
pookie will like
she'll sit by the sliding glass door
like all night looking out like waiting
for that kitty
all right they're saying nori is
terrible i like what he does the news
bella says nori sounds drunk rick says
if you have youtube chat they have a
youtube channel but they only upload
little clips
dan says they're becoming obsolete
because people getting sick of their
greed yeah
exactly there's a way around everybody
now
not a model they like well that's okay i
like to be able to work around people
that
are in my way it's gonna eventually
affect everything
that's okay and uh they're just gonna
have to deal with it
mostly gonna affect big companies and
[ __ ] uh hollywood
disney uh just big [ __ ] cable
channels
but actually uh nobody needs them their
product is inferior
um also education will totally be
changed it's another inferior product
um you can teach kids things over the
internet they're not even going to
schools in some of these states anymore
they're just doing the [ __ ] from home
the internet is the source of all
knowledge what the [ __ ] you
i look at what i can learn on the
internet now i compare that to middle
school and high school and [ __ ]
that one year of college i did and i was
just like the [ __ ] on the internet blows
away
all that stuff you know what i mean it's
it's just
better so that's just another piece of
paper they sell you i'm gonna get you
another drink
okay yeah you good okay go ahead and
entertain them jenny
yeah we were we were talking about
dracula when he came back in okay so
sophie yeah sophie says i haven't seen
that many versions of dracula but it's
always been a pet peeve of mine that no
one can seem to make one straight from
the novel
see that's that's what really bothers me
it's like the novel is really really
good i know that it's written in like
epistolary style yes that's harder to
adapt i get that
um so i did like that francis ford
coppola like kind of
you know took the time to make it seem
like it's like you know they have a lot
of journals and letters and stuff the
way the novel is written
but i don't know why
people take so many liberties with it
the weird thing about i just and
like look don't get me wrong i love the
1979
dracula from 1979 like for with franklin
angela rather
um it's more based on the play
which i guess the bella lugosi one was
too
so a lot of the [ __ ] from the novel is
left out and i had forgotten because i'd
seen that movie a bunch of times then we
watched it again
i think like last night and
i had forgotten that that whole entire
first
like third of the novel i think it's the
third of jonathan harker
in transylvania like being trapped in
the castle and like the vampire hoes and
all that kind of stuff
um that's like not in the movie
the movie starts with dracula
arriving thank you arriving on the ship
um to whitby so there is no transylvania
in the book in the movie at all um so
like i said it's more based on the stage
play
another weird thing they did and i saw
another adaptation that did this as well
and i'm just
i'm not [ __ ] on it i just don't know
why they did it they
switched lucy and mina because in the
book
lucy westinra is the first victim of
dracula she dies
she comes back as a vampire she starts
killing babies she becomes the blue fur
lady
all that kind of stuff okay so that
happens in the movie
and i've forgotten they showed a [ __ ]
[ __ ] bloody dead baby
in the movie so you know um but that was
mina
in the movie and another weird thing
they did
was that well hi sweetie you just came
back in though
yeah it's still fresh out there though
she's like but yeah but maybe my friend
might come on the back porch
yeah her little friend comes to the back
porch sometimes
she'll usually show up at like two or
three in the morning and be like me
me me like and then pookie will go to
the window and be like
hey hey other kitty that looks like me
and the other kid be like hey
other kitty that also looks like me and
they'll look at each other through the
glass
it's really super weird but yeah so
so not only did they switch lucy and
mina they also made
lucy um dr
seward's daughter so dr seward was
played by donald pleasance in this
version
fun fact uh yeah so they made lucy dr
seward's daughter
and they made meena ben helsing's
daughter
so in this version mina is the one who
gets killed and there's not even the
whole like hey three bites and then she
wasted away and then became a vampire
pretty much
dracula comes in she's like well hey
sexy what's up and he bites her and she
dies the next day
and then they bury her and then she like
comes back to life and starts like
killing
babies and whatnot and then they call
van helsing
and he's dutch for some well he's not
dutch for some reason he's dutch because
he's touched in the book but mina isn't
so the fact that they made him her dad
and then dr seward lucy's dad and then
like the [ __ ]
i don't know it seems really weird to me
so what we were talking about
so i don't know why they did that if
anybody could explain like what the
narrative significance of that was i
would really appreciate it
one thing we were talking about last
night and i meant to look this up today
and i totally forgot because i was doing
some other [ __ ]
okay i haven't read the book in probably
15
years what
okay what is the significance of the
renfield
character we were talking about because
that's what i just said so in the book
please correct me if i'm wrong somebody
that's read it more recently than me
because it's been a long time since i've
read it i couldn't make sense of it
renfield i thought was the first
solicitor before harker
yeah i thought that he had gone
and tried to do the [ __ ] with dracula
like because the whole
the whole um point of the solicitor
going
to transylvania to dracula's castle
because he was buying
property in england and they had a
solicitor take to take the papers there
because they didn't have the internet
back then
so you know somebody had to actually go
and he had to sign the papers
so i thought renfield was the first
solicitor
and he went there and then dracula
made him gave him to the hose or gave
him he didn't make him a vampire but he
like promised to make him a vampire and
made him like his
servant kind of so he's kind of like a
half fish
vampire right yeah but then he comes
back to england and then he's in dr
seward's asylum
and doesn't do much eating bugs and [ __ ]
and yeah that was only oh i never really
figured out
what his significance to the story was
i mean like why missing something we're
just saying like why did dracula need
him
yeah that's what we were talking about
doesn't really say why and
he doesn't really need him and he
doesn't get anything done
when he gets to [ __ ] is he just there
to [ __ ]
trumpet the coming of dracula i kind of
feel like maybe that's why he was
because here's the thing now i'm not
going to [ __ ] on bram stoker i know he's
dead
and everything like that but i want to
[ __ ] on bram stoker dracula's a classic
i love that novel but
bram stoker had kind of a thing
for ripping off sheridan lefonu
dracula little bit of a rip-off of
carmilla even some of his
short stories because even like a couple
short stories that i did on my witching
hour show
um bram stoker did a story called a
short story called the judge's house
and it was a total rip-off of a sheridan
lefinu story from
30 or 40 years earlier called um i think
it was called
an account of some strange occurrences
at anger street
right and it was almost the exact same
story
well it was the exact same story he just
wrote it a little bit different
um so bram stoker he
borrowed some [ __ ] is is what i'm saying
from chernobyl
um he borrowed a bunch of [ __ ] from
carmilla but you know
as i said dracula's a classic but
i don't know there's no purpose for him
in the story
but like i said i'm not i thought i'd
have to go back and read the novel
because i can't really remember
in in the movies there's no real purpose
for him
if they're based on the novel we have to
go back to like i said
i don't think i've ever read the novel
i've read parts of it
or i remember parts of it from what i
remember it was written like a lovecraft
story a bunch of letters
it wasn't like something that was it is
there is no narrative
it's all letters journal entries all
like it's epistolary
yeah which that's kind of like a found
footage book
which was real high tech in that yeah
yeah well a lot of uh victorian era
writers did that kind of
yeah they're trying to make you think
it's a real occurrence sure there's no
real
action yeah they're trying to give you
like some very similitude
whenever i see renfield in the movies he
doesn't really serve any purpose to
drive the [ __ ]
plot forward other than being just
just a crazy person that's kind of like
hey exactly this is coming my lord is
coming
so [ __ ] what what are you here for
what do you do what have you done
what does he need you for none of that's
really clear
um it's weird because i got apprehended
doing something i guess buying property
but wasn't that transaction already
closed when he took the
the paperwork to [ __ ] vlockia and had
him sign it
what's he need what's he needed for i
just don't understand what
now i'm some people are going to say
well he's doing this and that
that's not what i'm saying why was he
written into the story
that's what i'm asking why was he
written into the story because
the narrative of the story doesn't
require a character like that
well now i need to re-read the novel it
makes me such a long i'm just doing this
on the basis of the movies what i
remember in the movies
but the movie is kind of wildly yeah
they vary guys i just want to know what
the deal was in the goddamn book
because in the movies he's a weak
character that
isn't really needed to drive the
narrative forward who
he doesn't do anything other than eat
some bugs and say oh
he's coming basically he's coming i was
there i saw him
so what why'd he hire you what are you
needed for
you know i just didn't know that it's
almost kind of seems like something's
missing like something got edited out
well like i said i'd have to go back and
read the novel i'm just kind of going on
you know and like i said we were talking
about adaptations and like sophie was
saying there really hasn't been
um a really
you know very accurate adaptation
well it's kind of like frankenstein no
one's really done an accurate
adaptation of frankenstein either like i
understand
that this is victorian era and stuff is
structured differently i guess
like it says his significance is to is a
narrative device
that's what yeah that's what i'm saying
it's like i feel like he was just kind
of put in there
as like to create mood
and that's what i said last night we
were watching the movie i said he was
just put in there as like a harbinger of
like
you know doom to come yeah i kind of
feel like
yeah which maybe would have been more
effective
nowadays i kind of feel like you can't
get away with just putting a character
in there for that purpose they have to
have another purpose
right like an organic modern a modern
audience doesn't buy that
but i guess a victorian one does
yeah you're just dealing with this
different different i'm you know i
really love
um victorian horror fiction like i said
i read a lot of it
you know i i read some of them for my
witching hour show
but they there is a a large difference
in structure to what you would do
nowadays
and i do kind of feel like maybe some of
it is
um you know just because that culture
is you know we don't live in that
culture anymore so i do kind of feel
like sometimes i read the story and it
always comes
it kind of feels like i'm missing
something or there's some [ __ ] left out
or
[ __ ] is left hanging but maybe people
didn't feel like that back in the day
like like i said maybe because i don't
have the same cultural context
victorian culture was spiritualist yeah
they had
they believed in ouija boards and you
know
tarot cards and they had more time on
their hands
trail so things were more atmospheric
so dan may be correct it's just to
create mood
i well that was the impression that i
got and then when you look at
lovecraft lovecraft's writing are kind
of [ __ ]
hearkening back to writings like this
and lovecraft isn't about action it's
more about mood
although the weird thing about lovecraft
i feel like he's right on that
cusp between like yeah being
like atmospheric victorian and also
being really modern
yeah um which i guess why everybody
still remembers him nowadays because
of that he was kind of like taking the
best of both worlds you know what i'm
saying
but i do kind of feel like um you know i
was just doing i i was recording a
witching hour show today with an amelia
b
edwards story um called was it an
illusion
and they did a lot of ghost stories they
loved their [ __ ] ghost stories back
in the victorian era which i did also a
lot of them are kind of like similar
though
they're you can read the comments in
there yeah we know all that
people like uh
serpent says i remember it was to
describe more of the psychological
control dracula had over his yeah yeah
yeah
and then amanda says dracula doesn't
need renfield redfield wants his feet
off dracula he's kind of like someone
who's crazy enough to prey on draco
it's a narrative okay that actually
makes a lot more sense
maybe what i was thinking about but the
thing is though is that yeah you could
say that but
he doesn't still he doesn't have much of
a purpose in the story
it does add mood though yeah like he's
not driving the story forward
he doesn't really go anywhere or do
anything
not yeah not really he doesn't seem to
be serving
draco the interesting thing about i mean
he's not what is he doing for dracula
well and in some adaptations he kind of
is
more of a servant than others i kind of
feel like the one that we were talking
about the 1979 one
renfield he's kind of like
i don't even think in the 1979 version
we just watched it last night
he wasn't even did he even go to
transylvania no not clear i don't i
don't think he did
he and he wasn't in the asylum from the
beginning because he came up to the
shipwreck
like you know where the dracula's ship
like crashed into the thing and like the
wolf jumped off and the dude was like
lashed to the wheel or whatever
and like renfield comes up there and he
still seems pretty sane at this point so
they
they don't put him in the asylum until
later when he starts like eating bugs
and acting weird and [ __ ]
yeah and it's and it's i can understand
if he escapes from prison
and then actually helps dracula do [ __ ]
you know what i mean to take over that
never happens
basically all that happens is he sits up
in the insane asylum
um talks about dracula dracula shows up
and says you told them about me you
[ __ ] betrayed me and he kills him
so it's just like there's not a lot
there in terms of
character to actually develop the story
but
i think dan is right more about tone and
mood
that's what i was saying it's another
person to kill i mean
yeah cannon fodder he's another person
he's the person to shout out warnings
that [ __ ] you know
my lord is coming or whatever you know
and he's like a cassandra
right you know that's probably what it
is kind of figure
something to stress out the characters
back in england yeah so like what the
[ __ ] was he talking about yeah
that's probably maybe what the his crazy
rantings have something to do with all
this crazy [ __ ] that's going
all these men in this guy these
beautiful women dying of
weird diseases yeah that really wouldn't
fly today
you'd he the renfield character would
have to do a lot more
he would have to be directly tied to
this whole carfax abbey [ __ ]
you know what i mean and these girls
you'd have to show up on scene
that's how well you would have to link
everything together yeah and he's not
the people seeing this wouldn't
necessarily link all this together
besides
his words i mean i kind of feel like
the thing about it is that nowadays you
know even though everybody's like
talking about oh everyone's so dumb
nowadays or
i don't think that i think everyone's a
lot more sophisticated yeah it is well
like i said they had more time on their
particular well i mean particularly as
regards
to fiction people don't have a lot of
patience
for fictional characters fictional plot
lines
still like that doesn't link into one
it's everything has to link together you
can't put [ __ ] in there that's like just
throw away or useless people are going
to call you out for that
so you know you know tyler says we are
what we are is awesome
yeah i agree i really really did uh like
that movie i don't think
that's the thing he doesn't do anything
that's not really needed he's just an
extra tool for the script yeah
i think so which you know that's fine
it's a long novel
i'm kind of like i don't know i have
this weird fascination like i said i'm
really into
like victorian horror fiction i'm really
fascinated
by all of the adaptations particularly
of dracula but of other victorian era
fiction as well because
you know a lot a lot of the stories have
had adaptations
but the interesting thing i think
dracula was probably
probably i don't know maybe frankenstein
might have some competition in that area
but i feel like dracula has the most
adaptations of it
and i feel like it's been changed the
most
and a lot of the changes that they make
from the novel i'm not really sure why
they made them
it's like i can see why you'd want to
put renfield in there because you know
he eats bugs and he's crazy and like
that's a good thing to put in a movie
but i don't know some of the changes
that are made in some of the adaptations
are just
baffling to me like like i said as much
as i love
the 1979 version that we watched with
frank langella in it
why why why did they switch
lucy and mina and why did they make dr
seward lucy's dad
and van helsing mina's dad why did they
do that
that just seems it just seems bizarre to
me like why would they do that remember
that youtube channel that compared
all of the dracula movies yeah it was
sitting in massachusetts
and then he did all the differences i've
watched that video like three or four
times i tried to compare him to the
actual
yeah would you remember the name of that
video well he just
um [ __ ] man he called it a massacre
it was in a massacre if you serve
cinematic or dracula you'll probably
find it's just
james i love him he's awesome it's a
good it's a great
show and we saw that what about six
months ago a year
eight months ago not even not even uh
well i've watched it two or three
there's a [ __ ] ton of differences and i
think he actually said the closest one
to the novel
wasn't it one of the kind of the b movie
it was the francis ford coppola one
and it was a tie with the bbc version
bbc version
which were the most accurate and even
and they weren't super accurate
the only reason why yes and he goes
through like he picked the 12
kind of biggest or most accurate ones
and then he goes through
every single one and is kind of like
hey this one has this plot point or this
character taken out or whatever and he
just it's very meticulous
and i don't know why like i nerded out
over it
i watched it like three or four times
yeah it is a nerdy video but
i get it it's classic literature that's
the kind of [ __ ] i do and there's a [ __ ]
ton of movies which one of this is the
closest one and he comes out and says
none of them
these two are pretty close but there's
differences between and i mean the
francis ford coppola one the weird thing
about that and i think we mentioned this
when we reviewed it not too long ago
was that in a lot of ways
it's the most accurate but it's also the
least accurate because
he had most the most stuff from the
novel but he also added a bunch of [ __ ]
that wasn't in the novel you know what
i'm saying
i will give mad respect to francis ford
coppola for actually putting [ __ ]
quincy morris in there as a character
which almost
none of the other dracula adaptations do
because in the novel there was a whole
uh you know lucy had three suitors
and that was kind of like a whole you
know [ __ ] there was quincy there was
arthur
there was uh whatever the other [ __ ]
dude's name was and they were
i can't remember but um you know that it
was like a whole like
vampire hunting gang right and
so i like anyone so pretty much every
adaptation like film adaptation
has left quincy out because i see why
um because they're like look we don't
need this many characters we don't need
all these people you don't need
her having three boyfriends like
fighting the [ __ ] vampire we just
like come
you know compress it all into one
character it's a lot more
you know it's two less actors we have to
pay terry asked tom and jenny what's
your favorite horror movie about
i know mine mine would be alien one
too hard alien one it
okay can i say this is cheating
it's a three-way tie it's a three-way
tie between
the shining oh
god damn it the haunting from 1963
and suspiria from 1977
but the thing though god damn it okay
maybe it's a four-way tie i can't pick
well the thing about it is that like i
said since i'm so into horror
it's like i kind of like well my i have
to
i have to kind of like narrow it down to
like what's my favorite haunted house
movie
or what's my favorite monster movie or
what's my favorite
because i can't pick a favorite horror
movie if i if i had to pick a very very
favorite horror movie and you said this
is the only movie that you can take with
you to a desert island
and you have to just like watch this
every day forever
probably the shining shining would be my
second
because i can watch that i could watch
that every day and not get tired of it
the shining would be okay
the shining would be my second i'm still
going to put [ __ ] alien
as as that's legit that's true that's so
legit but
sophie when sophie showed up here she
had never seen alien or alien 2 none of
the alien friends yeah we showed her
both those
show on my big [ __ ] tv with the
[ __ ] real good edits and i showed her
the theatrical cut
of [ __ ] alien too blown away she
[ __ ] loved the first one i think she
liked the second one better and
she said and she's young yeah i mean
well younger than us
she's like uh yeah what was great about
alien too
is that all that stuff was really there
no cg
yep makes a huge difference she was
buying into it
some of that [ __ ] with the alien queen
i'm looking over and looking at her and
she's like going
[ __ ] because i mean it looks good
so good looks so much better than celia
so much better than cg and just the
writing and that was when cameron was
really on game
that's back when cameron's name meant
something he doesn't mean anything now
but
back in the days he did i'm gonna say
i mean i if i had to pick between the
two
i like i think i like alien a little bit
more than aliens
just because it's more horror movie than
an action movie yeah
it's more like a haunted house movie
aliens is not a horror movie it's an
action it's an
action but what's wrong with elements
yeah in the same way
terminator 1 and predator are action
with horror elements
alien terminator 1 is a jaws movie
basically
it's like jaws the terminator is the
shark basically yeah
i mean jaws is also yeah and [ __ ]
the best [ __ ] horror scythe the
horror war movie of all times was
[ __ ]
predator predators
the third one i like that one too that
was actually not bad yeah pretty good
i liked it dana ready says i know it's
boring but the exorcist is my favorite
honestly exorcist i don't find exorcists
boring at all
i'm throwing out [ __ ] ones honestly
when the exorcist when they re-released
it in the theaters i was [ __ ] first
in line to see that [ __ ] because i never
got to see it on the big screen
because i was too young um i had seen it
multiple times on cable but like when it
came out the big screen
and they added all the [ __ ] to it like
all the pazuzu
like [ __ ] you know subliminal [ __ ]
yeah i went and saw that and i had a
[ __ ] great time um
i love the exorcist honestly i don't
think it's boring at all i think it's
fantastic well the thing about it is
that i don't know i i think there's a
thing
and you know this has kind of been uh
you know talked about the horror
community a lot
nowadays too because some people like i
like really like slow burn horror
i kind of feel like you have to have a
build up you have to give a [ __ ]
about the characters in horror
particularly in horror
because you have to care when something
really [ __ ] up happens to them
and if you don't take the time to
establish
that relationship between you and the
characters in the movie
then no one's going to give a [ __ ] when
they get killed or when bad [ __ ] happens
to them
horror is tone yeah and you have to have
tone to get that
like uh you could say uh exorcist would
be your best one
but there's a lot of shitty movies that
can kind of i enjoy just as much as
exorcists like andyville horror that's a
shitty movie
it's [ __ ] great though [ __ ] you
know i mean it's i'm here to watch it
today you're like man i have a lot of
affection for you
bill [ __ ] some of the [ __ ] on the
antibiotic you could watch every other
[ __ ] and you go like well some of the
episodes on the haunting [ __ ] first
and second season are actually better
sure than that technically but that
doesn't matter there's something about
being there at that place at that time
when that was a new movie watching it
you can get a connection with amityville
[ __ ]
even though that's a [ __ ] crap movie
in a way not
it has great acting it has good writing
yeah
it's just technically and the some of
the special effects are not that
cheesy but you know but that's that's
good
and then uh some of the horror that is
really good you know kind of forgotten
the omen
all three of them we watched them and
they were [ __ ] they stand tested we
just watched
all three omen three was [ __ ] great
last week
the final conflict much better than i
remembered it and honestly the first
domain i never get tired of that either
yeah it's good one i could watch that
the second
one's okay too but then the third one
came back and did some [ __ ] cool [ __ ]
that was fun but it's like i i liked the
second one just because it was so
somewhat over the top like i loved the
over-the-top depths in that
it's like it just [ __ ] cracked me up
one one thing i wanted to say though
before we kind of moved on from the
exorcist
was that i think the reason that the
exorcist is still remembered nowadays
is because they take the time to
establish
reagan as a character and her mom and
the relationship between them
you care about reagan so when she first
when she first starts like manifesting
like some demonic [ __ ]
and you can relate to
her acting weird because she was such a
lovely girl before
and her mom just being like what the
[ __ ] is going on and she like taking her
at all this like the hospital and
everything like that
so they spend so much time building that
up
that when the demonic [ __ ] happens it's
way scarier i think
because you care about those two
characters
yeah if you don't take the time to do
that and it's hard to do because
sometimes you try to take the time to
like no one cares like no one gives a
[ __ ] and it's just boring
but i don't think that movie is boring
at all if you like
exorcist one go straight to exorcist
three don't even bother with exorcist
two just go right to exodus three that's
another classic
real good movie that's about the phantom
killer
texarkana yeah directed by the same dude
that did this that [ __ ] bigfoot movie
about
with in arkansas boggy creek yeah
boggy creek legend of boggy creek and
boggy creek 2 and the legend
actually exorcist three was still good
it had a lot of good acting on it that
had
i mean george c i forgot how i forgot
how
no he wasn't who was well he was yeah he
was an exorcist three i thought you were
talking about elementary
i'm talking about exodus three yeah and
brad doroth was in that as well
brad doroth was voice of chucky yeah
now among other things and uh they're
going in there they're talking about
this is for you damian yeah the omen the
omen series
or we have all three of them no we only
have two
one and two well we watched one and two
on hulu for free yeah
so we don't have those on blu-ray no and
then the third one
we rented it we thought that it was
available on hulu but they were like
no you gotta like get the hbo upgrade
and we're like [ __ ] that so then we went
to amazon
i was kind of i liked almond one i was
kind of sick of it because i've seen it
so many times
nah man i've seen it so many times it
was
what didn't really affect me that much
three or two was good because they had
the military
school [ __ ] and i came out of military
school so you know i was like yeah yeah
yeah i know exactly yeah
i'm i'm the devil too you know but
anyway
but anyways when they got you on the
devil when when i got when we got the
[ __ ] the final conflict though i
thought that was like a strong movie
and the score was [ __ ] great i mean i
like the first one
the best but number three is pretty
[ __ ] good
who's that dude that did the score
what's his name
[ __ ] dude [ __ ] the dude that
writes all the badass scores
[Music]
uh it wasn't john williams it was uh it
was that
it was the other jewish guy goldblum no
no not goldberg
goldsmith goldsmith gold spells
goldsmith yeah there you go
that dude he can [ __ ] that dude does
the [ __ ] score
that [ __ ] that score was [ __ ] epic
from almond three epic
i forgot how he jacked over there i
forgot how hot sam neil was back in the
day
when he was younger that whole movie was
good
i liked it the final concert i had
forgotten how good it was it's
it's weird because we talked about it
last week but
omen 2 i thought i had seen it but
then like when we watched it and the
dude got cut in half in the elevator i'm
like dude
maybe i didn't see this because i would
have remembered this
yeah you know what i'm saying well there
was something about the whole omen
trilogy growing up in the time that i
grew up
that was taking me back to the
[ __ ] man who saw tomorrow back before
him
it was yeah it was a line before its
time
well the thing what was that [ __ ]
that's or someone orson wells trying to
[ __ ]
sell you that the antichrist was coming
the great king of
terror bringing down fire on the new
city i yeah i feel like that whole
zeitgeist thing that was going on
the thing about it there was like there
was so much apocalyptic horror there was
like a lot of religious horror that
happened in the 70s
because i kind of feel like there was
that whole thing where people thought
the world was going to end in 1999
because of nostradamus
because like i said we didn't have the
internet back then so everybody was just
kind of like
reliant on um books and
like weird like documentaries and
whatnot
so there was a lot of that going on and
i do feel like there was a lot of
apocalyptic religious word that came out
so particularly in light of the exorcist
and all that [ __ ]
so what [ __ ] serpent got me bro he
goes the the antichrist is coming in the
form of paul massan
right you guys he knows exactly what
we're talking about i've
not seen it please youtube
yeah and look at i don't know what you
have to search for but please like
search for the man who saw them all the
no no no like search for orson welles
drunk
yeah because that's a good one there are
some outtakes of him doing that
commercial
yeah they're
so good well they said that when you
hired when you hired [ __ ]
um [ __ ] i mean well you knew what you
were getting
into you had to buy all the drinks
he was gonna be [ __ ] loaded there
were gonna be a lots and lots of takes
and you were gonna pay for all that film
footage because this is orson
[ __ ] wells that voice alone
i mean he just showed up you know can
you imagine
being [ __ ] that famous all
300 pounds that people are willing to
accommodate you to that extent put up
with your [ __ ]
wow yeah i wish i had that but he
he what they would call nowadays
gravitas he had [ __ ] gravitas yeah he
just wouldn't make
he could make anything sound important
and that's why they put him on when he
was
sobering yeah yeah
[Laughter]
what's funny is like that's a
[ __ ] that would have met
ed wood and ed wood would have just been
jacked sure
you know the thing about like what
i i think what amused me the most about
those outtakes from the paul masson
wines
commercial was that when they did the
outtakes
orson welles clearly had no
idea of what he was where he was
yeah what are you talking about i don't
think he even knew what
dimension he was in he didn't know
anything about paul and the other two
actors
i love this the other two actors are
like the man and woman at the table and
they're just kind of like
and they're just kind of like they're
trying to like play along and they're
just kind of like we have no idea like
what and he had no idea where he was
that's how [ __ ] up he was and it was
just it was so [ __ ] funny
and then it was so [ __ ] funny to me
because i'm like
these are the outtakes but then you saw
the commercial and he got the [ __ ]
together at some point
and got a take in there that no one
noticed anything so it was like good for
him good for him it probably took
50 takes maybe but you know we'll see
somebody mentioned carnival of souls
yeah which you we should probably review
that at some point because
i honestly i love carnival souls and i
think it was really
ahead of its time in a lot of ways brad
jones just said
yo at me i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about
i don't know what you talk about yo tom
okay i'm here
[ __ ] up but i'm telling you um another
classic
you can watch for free on youtube is the
man who saw tomorrow starring orson
welles
and that [ __ ] it's in nostradamus
this is before the history channels okay
let's try this [ __ ]
they were history channeling before
there was a history channel
and they would [ __ ] pull these
nostradamus quatrains and [ __ ]
get orson well the writing was
beautiful at the time they would start
off small
and then they would [ __ ] build up and
build up
and try to make you think that these
quatrains actually happened and to
establish
proof that nostradamus's
predictions were coming true all right
because it had come true
in the past about the french revolution
and hitler
and just every [ __ ] thing
and then then orson [ __ ] gets you he
tells you you need to prepare yourself
now because gonna have in 1999
the future and the few and the three and
the nostradamus
the antichrist to come you know and then
[ __ ] he starts going on on the
[ __ ] antichrist to come
and that [ __ ] [ __ ] was so impressive
that i swear to god
you thought there were in the 1990s i
was still expecting
some [ __ ] to [ __ ] hit the world trade
center
and when [ __ ] 9 11 happened i was
like
dude it's a couple years late but that's
about what orson welles said well you
know that stupid [ __ ] hit the [ __ ]
world trade center in 1993 right that
[ __ ]
dude yeah yeah but that wasn't 1999
though
no i know and you know it's just it just
they're like what but he had
close enough close enough close enough
but then there's some other people that
came and said well our calendar is wrong
you see because no strategies talking
about
them nostradamus was talking about the
old [ __ ] julian calendar back
before rome changed that [ __ ] you know
so there's
a bunch of different way you're always
going to find a way
to jimmy that into
a true prediction i know it's because
there's a lot of quadrants
it's basically a horoscope that's why
people are still talking about that
[ __ ]
yeah centuries later yeah because he was
real good at that he's real good at that
[ __ ] he could write down a little
quatrain and he wrote down thousands of
them in no particular order
that could fit anything most of them
boring
but the [ __ ] interesting sounding
ones yeah everybody talks about
yeah there's a [ __ ] ton of them that are
boring that nobody ever talks about
it's because he covered all his bases he
wrote down all kinds of stuff that
possibly statistically could fit to
something somewhere eventually
because he was making money off of
telling fortunes to rich man
[ __ ] man i gotta keep like scrying
you're gonna be looking into the flames
i can make it describe that i should
make up all kinds of crying is kind of
like the old-fashioned
[ __ ] italian version of what we would
call
mississippi ciphering see y'all have
mathematics looking into a bowl of water
reciting some visions we cipher a mirror
works too
no sophie says carnival of souls might
be my favorite horror movie of all time
that i've seen so
i've seen it but i don't remember i like
there's something about
carnival of souls one it was super ahead
of its time
it's like it just has this vibe
about it man i don't i don't know what
it is they didn't mean to do it
it just happened it was like this
organic
creepy it just that has this whole like
[ __ ] aesthetic to it that they didn't
actually even intend
but it just kind of turned out like that
and
it's amazing i love carnival souls
actually
yeah mike uh mike barrett yeah orson
welles was probably drunk off his face
with that yeah he was always [ __ ]
drunk he was yeah
you know brad jones nori sucks and
george knapp actually
is the best filling host every sunday on
costa because jimmy church is a good
host he's got faded but yeah actually
out of all the
modern guys that are happening right now
i would [ __ ] choose
uh jimmy church jimmy church is a great
host and he's although if he says
dub dub dub dub dub dub yeah get [ __ ]
crazy punch somebody although he is uh
and he you can hear him on fade to black
i subscribe to him on youtube
fade to black um a decent show good show
i like him
he does kind of have that jewel he does
kind of have that um
george nori kind of the condescension no
no no no no no no no no no no no
no talking about damn bell art bell
i'm [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] dan bell is
dan bell's another guy
he does kind of have that bell quality
to him
because what made art good
is that you could tell that art was a
nice guy
he was just doing his job he was trying
to entertain you and get you off
he's kind of like your uncle you know
come on with me and i'm gonna we're
gonna talk about i said that when you
were gone i said it was very evocular
yeah yeah he's like he's like you know
come with me today we will talk about
the martian sexual slave camp in the den
cause that's one thing that you're
talking about yeah yeah yeah yeah
we will discuss the child slave camps
you know underneath towards the core of
the martian plant
sure is that the thing that's like what
the [ __ ] you talking about like what you
you know and that's that's and oh my god
it's
real he would get you suspended your
disbelief
well that's yeah i kind of feel like
that's what his greatest strength was
yeah
yeah there were shows where you know
that art knows this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
well i hope he knows it's [ __ ] i
hope so but he's trying to [ __ ] put
on a good show and get you to at least
consider well yeah he just wants people
to like listen to
to enjoy the show sure now there were
other shows where
um art took the [ __ ] seriously he's
thinking there's something to it
you know i mean we had a big guest they
were talking about ufo reports and stuff
you know what i mean
yeah you know because that's what the
military reported
so you know he'd be off into that too
some of this [ __ ]
was like you know that that's probably
not happening but yeah
it was happening like sidonia yeah like
that dude talking about the [ __ ] plan
that the [ __ ] cities on mars like
this is the ruins of an old city on mars
it was
really his name well he made a whole
career off of
oh i know what are you talking about
[ __ ] martian satellite folks well i
think we mentioned because remember we
did that show a long time ago about
like [ __ ] about mars yeah i can't
remember his name though i'll probably
remember
his whole career was to go on [ __ ]
art bell's show
and look at old [ __ ] low-res [ __ ]
martian satellite photos
and say if you look here and find some
[ __ ] there that is an old colosseum
paranormal you look at this thing here
this thing here
that's a that is a martian downtown yeah
that is a martian elementary school
right there
yeah and he's not saying they excelled
at that time he was saying they were
ancient ruins
i know you're staying there yeah no i'm
just [ __ ] clearing it up for the
audience
he wasn't saying that it was modern he
was saying that it was from millions and
millions of years ago which made it more
plausible
like yeah maybe millions of millions of
years but then later on
to say yeah then later on they'd have
more
they'd have like really high res high
resolution
[ __ ] photos and that [ __ ] and you're
like it's not there that's what the hill
yeah it's a hill well you know you can
uh you can build a
big narrative out of some blurry ass
photos yeah just saying
uh dana ready is asking tom and jenny
what is your opinion on rob zombie
um okay i'm gonna try to be like
diplomatic about this look
okay i love white zombie i love the band
i love rob zombie as a
musician as a filmmaker
um i liked house of a thousand corpses a
lot
uh i liked what was the second one i
don't remember
what was whatever the second one was
called i like that one
um the one with the firefight firefly
family good
movie however his remake of halloween
made me want to punch him in the face um
one of the very few movies that i saw in
the theater that i was like
yeah i don't i might just leave because
i was very angry that he gave a
backstory
to michael myers like look he was just a
poor abused child i'm like dude
don't do that do you not know anything
about horror it's like it's much scarier
there you go um i remember that one i
liked it i liked that one too i think
that was better than the first one
um i don't know i haven't seen house of
a thousand quarters since yeah um
you know so i'm not [ __ ] on him
entirely but i got really angry
at his halloween remake just because i
don't think
like i get he he seems really into
horror but i don't
know if he knows what
works in horror it's you know it because
i feel like house of a thousand corpses
and stuff like that is really good as
like shock horror
like [ __ ] that you're watching it and
just like man this is [ __ ] up
that's what it was it was in it's yeah
but if you're remaking
halloween let's say that's a different
uh kettle of fish and i do feel like if
you're making
that kind of movie demystifying
your main villain is a mistake
so i i kind of feel like he should have
known that
and the fact that he did that anyway
just like really really made me angry
like he just wanted to make shocking
horror torture porn
like really gory [ __ ] i'm in for i like
that kind of [ __ ] too
um but don't try to remake halloween
and take the villain and explain
him as an abused child
because that's not working for me as far
as this music goes though i like to
speak
i really like white zombie that first
album i did too that was that was yeah
and groundbreaking at the time
especially they had that damn [ __ ]
thunder kiss 65 was a real good one and
then
it was another song he had a song it was
about it was about the omega man
and it was also about i i am legend it
was i am legend then their mega man
combined together in one song it was
really good i liked that one had an
instrumental intro and then it [ __ ]
went in
kind of sounded he was kind of sounded
like [ __ ]
um what was his name sounded like
neville
sounded like neville talking mixed in
with the vincent price from
yeah and i respect that he's like super
into like
old school horror like i love that yeah
i just i think i got mad at him i wasn't
mad at him prior to the halloween remake
after i saw the halloween remake and i
paid to watch it in the theater
that i don't know it just it made me
angry because i was like look if you
want to make your own movies
and you want to do because like i said
house of a thousand corpses
[ __ ] devil's rejects great um
you know yeah i'm into that [ __ ] but
like i said i'm not always in the mood
for it but
you know i like slow burn ghost story
horror i like torture porn kind of
murder it's like i like all that kind of
[ __ ] i love
watching that's your shirt sick we made
that shirt i made this actually
just designed it i printed it this is um
absolution
is a it's a concert goth rock festival
yeah uh they do it well they've done it
two years running they were gonna do it
uh this year but obviously i got
postponed um
it's also got a back that has all the
[ __ ] uh yeah it's like
it's like a three-day i don't think i
have the back anymore but i definitely i
think i have the front
i'm not sure with all the bands i'm not
sure i cleared that frame or not
i don't know we might have but yeah so
yeah it's like a three-day it's in tampa
and they do like a three-day goth rock
festival they've done it for the past
couple years
couldn't do it this past year obviously
but uh we went to the one and i and we
made these shirts too we screen printed
them
how long we've been streaming three
hours and 49 minutes
yeah it's probably time to shut it down
do you think yeah i'm still having a
good i'm still having a little
four-hour show though that's all right i
can't believe
that stream hasn't dropped i'm so
[ __ ] happy and no one's complained
about the audio i guess it sounds good
so i fixed it
which hooray um let me
four hours is long for a show though
oh you tapping out well you always want
to leave people wanting more
[Laughter]
you always only want more
i yeah i did i did like the rob zombie
question though i thought that
yeah is there any more questions guys i
have so i have such mixed feelings
yeah and like every time i see him on
because you know i think he was on like
the joe bob briggs thing and here we go
i wrote it down already wrote it down um
i i
actually have been wanted to do that one
because like i said we did a show about
the phantom killer and that's kind of
what that's based on
and the dude charles b pierce that
directed that
was also did the boggy creek movies
which uh a couple of those i've seen on
mst so you know
um but talent dreaded sundown is
actually really good we should probably
do carnival of souls too
i think i have carnival of souls on
dvd or blu-ray but it might be a
rifftrax version
so i'm not sure like it might be
colorized
but i think i have it someplace town
that droid it's undone i'm not sure i
have it or not
but it's not exactly like
the crimes and i do
feel like some of the details of the
crimes have been
subsumed by the [ __ ] that happened in
the movie because the movie was so
popular
but we definitely will have to do that
movie at some point
i feel like i should put that in the
rotation
can we even watch it anywhere i don't
know i don't know i'll have to look it
up
it might be on [ __ ] some [ __ ] what
time on friday
i kind of feel like we well we had ken
asked us because normally we would do 5
p.m
right ken asked us can we do [ __ ] a
little later
because he wanted to watch it when he
got home from work
so i don't know should we do six or
seven
for a friday on friday night we could do
six
maybe we should do six that'd be a good
compromise
because i don't know
i you know i don't know i i think it'll
be good because friday night
we may get home from work at six o'clock
you're watching dinner you can watch us
we'll be probably beyond performing
everybody's saying like four hours later
anyway yeah
i kind of feel like everyone's gonna
feel like that but like i said we have
like a lot of people that are in
different time zones
so it's really hard for us to you know
we're at eastern standard time it's i
don't even know what
what time is it for us now okay it's
quarter to nine
for us right now so i mean five is good
for us
and eastern standard because then you
know we can end the show and we still
have like time before we go to bed but
i don't know if it's friday night we
should probably like go a little bit
later
you examining your drink there's a
[ __ ] crack in there
oh yeah look at that maybe you should
throw that one out
yeah i probably should you might told it
it's holding fluid you might be drinking
little particles of glass right now and
they're
catching in your esophagus
and your intestines
okay well that's it for you guys um
there's no more questions
then we can uh tammy says she's from
australia we can go ahead and we can go
ahead and check out
we probably should we're almost at like
uh almost four hours
yeah uh amanda says i'm in pacific
standard time so when you guys start at
5 p.m it's like 2 p.m for me okay
so maybe it won't be so bad if we start
at like 6 or 7 00
p.m i don't know we'll figure it out
we'll figure it out by tomorrow and then
i'll make an announcement how about that
yep we'll sort it out because i don't
want everybody to be like
not knowing but like i said we will do
it friday night this week
all right so hopefully everybody had a
good time
i feel like it was a good discussion
this evening yeah we covered most of the
[ __ ] we wanted to cover we talked about
dracula we talked about goth [ __ ] we
talked about heat
we talked about all the [ __ ] that i said
we were gonna talk about right yeah
as far as i remember that's good i don't
wanna wake up at two or three in the
morning be like wait oh [ __ ] do we
forget to talk about that because
that should i do you guys um so you know
all right so
hopefully uh everybody had a good time
this evening i'm really glad the [ __ ]
stream didn't drop out
like it usually does and we will be back
on
friday night so don't forget friday
night
we'll figure out what time it is i'll
announce it tomorrow it'll be six or
seven
probably and uh we'll do the main show
which is going to be about the
disappearance of
db cooper yep um
so that should be fun you know something
about that yep yeah
know all about it so we're going to talk
about that yep that's what one in the
poll this week stevie cooper
we'll see you guys friday yeah friday
night and then
saturday night we'll probably go out yep
we'll get some video yeah maybe
yep we're saying that now but we
probably won't
[Laughter]
all right jenny shut it down all right
so thanks everybody for dropping by
remember like share subscribe and all
your social media blah blah blah
if you want a financial aid sports show
i know you guys mostly
do already go to our patreon page
patreon.com 13 o'clock podcast or go to
our blog 13 o'clockpodcast.wordpress.com
and there's a button in the sidebar that
goes to a paypal account if you'd like
to give a one-time donation
it is much appreciated we will see you
guys
friday night at whatever time i announce
tomorrow
thanks for buying as always and goodbye